good morning
i will now open the public hearing on
senate bill 313.
the committee recognizes representative
mcguire
thank you madam chair members of the
committee i'm carol mcguire
representing merrimack district 29 which
is allen's town epsom and pittsfield i'm
introducing senate bill 313
in lieu of senator gaida who is
unavailable at the moment he will be
with us this afternoon
and this is a bill to clean up
the problem between the oplc having
authority to
set fees
for the licensing boards
and
the boards having statutory license fees
in there
in their controlling statutes so
the basic part of the bill which starts
on page two
deletes the statutory fees for a number
of boards
and says that the
it and refers back to the
oplcs authority to set
fees
there's a study committee in parts one
and two
that i have an amendment which you
should have already that deletes the
study committee because
we also have senate bill 330 which has a
study committee on the scope
on the operations of the oplc and i
think the fee authority ought to be
combined with that study committee
rather than having two separate ones
just have one more extensive study
other than that i will try to ask answer
questions
there is one small error that needs to
be fixed the
mechanical licensing board
has to the
has to be corrected so that the fees go
into the
oplc fund rather than the general fund
because
uh
because of the change in the
connections or attachment
any questions
uh thank you um
looking at
um
page three starting at line 19 it's
about i think that's right well 21.
um as i recall we uh we had a bill that
eliminated the board of registration
medical technicians
and so how's that going to work if that
actually makes it through with this bill
that's a very good point we if
uh
assuming that the that
we should assume that the bills we have
passed have passed
and delete that section as well
thank you
see no further questions thank you
representative
you have a question
do you plan to put in that amendment
uh to change the fee allocation and the
uh
representative i haven't
had a chance to create it but i would be
would take care of him you're going to
take care okay
representative goalie
thank you just
as i'm going through this i'm just
looking at and i
still have some
questions as
the executive director
um
in the appointing of members
we're striking out a number of areas
where those who
seem to have the expertise and i'm
looking particularly under the
mechanical licensing board
that at least four appointed members and
this is line 11
in consultation with and the state fire
marshal is now strucking out and it's
with the office of professional
licensure with the approval of the
executive director shall adopt rules
i just want to make sure we're
all set with
um making sure that it's done correctly
and that
we make sure it states that the
boards specifically
uh are consulted and have
recommendations um
yes that that board is
not an advisory board
so it does it this says that it
it needs an affirmative vote
and in consulting i mean the currently
the
director
commissioner of safety
approves the rules but doesn't actually
write them
um
and i think this would be the same
process that the board develops the
rules and and
the commissioner of safety makes the
formal adoption after the board's
through with it
and that was just my concern because
we're striking out the commissioner and
the state fire marshal now and just
specifically pointing in
this
executive director
yes
that's because the board has been
moved really the board of fire control
is that uh
i know the mechanical board got moved to
oplc is the board of fire control then
moved
i think we've got somebody from old plc
that will that might be
better able to answer that question than
i am
okay thank you
sorry about that
representative schuett
thank you madam chair um it's looking as
though this bill is going to need uh
some corrections
so while you're at it i noticed on page
three line 33
ophthalmic dispensing should be o p h
t h a l m i c
there's a spelling error
i'm shocked
[Laughter]
filmic dispensers yes that's the most
likely one to be uh spelled incorrectly
okay
it's it's on line 33 you said yeah
and it's spelled correctly
on line 36 so it's
yep it's correct there okay
i suspect this should go
we will need a little combing to get the
like i said as long as you're fixing
other things
might as well get fixed too oh yeah no
sense not no sense leaving a spelling
spelling error
are there any further questions for
representative
mcguire thank you representative thank
you
mr trombley
i figured since you were so eager to
answer the questions that were asked
we'll just put you right in the hot seat
morning my name is bill trombley and i
am representing
the
pftf hvac association of new hampshire
uh and we're in favor of
313 as it's written i mean i should say
with the
amendment of changing the funds to go to
the
oplc
and just to answer the question
is uh
the way it's written with the mechanical
board is the board has to approve
everything and then we get the approval
of either the executive director or the
staff
um because they help us write the rules
and they're going through the process
right now and it's a pretty good synergy
of how they uh how they are doing it
because
we're plumbers not lawyers and we have
ideas and
they they
they do the spelling check and
and the
the commas and periods and everything
else like that so
um the association is in favor of 313
and we'll be
want to be very
active with the study committee when
they
talk about the fees with the old plc uh
it's our belief that
that the board should have um say in
what fees are
being put on to our licensees and so we
just want to be part of that
are there any questions for mr tremblay
representative scitec
mr trombley what's pfgs it's plumbers
fuel gas fitters and hvac
so it covers the the mechanical law so
it's we have about uh last count about
300 members or so in the state of new
hampshire
thank you thank you
any further questions
thank you very much
jessica i know i'm going to slaughter
this last name
all right good morning
when i hear jessica in a pause i usually
know that's my cue so
um
good morning my name is jessica
calipaletis i'm the director for the
division of enforcement at oplc and i am
here on behalf of oplc this morning
oplc supports sb 313 as amended and its
objectives
the one thing we would note which i
think you've already heard is
that the amendment reincorporated the
language requiring the mechanical
licensing board fees to be deposited in
the general fund
and if passed this would effectively
eliminate the board's ability to fund
itself through its licensure fees uh so
oplc would propose modifying this
language to make it clear that these
funds are to be posited in the oplc fund
uh the executive director lindsey
courtney had provided a letter to the
committee
that provided additional details on our
position
but i'd be happy to answer any questions
the committee may have
thank you very much thank you
are there any members of the public
representative schmidt
i'll get a pink card for you when i'm
done um so
just for the
public's edification to some degree and
for also for those members of the
committee who are so
somewhat newer than some of the some of
us who have been here for a while um the
idea of
this bill is in uh pursuit of
the
perfection if you will of
the oplc which uh which the committee
will have heard in some of our earlier
bills where we were trying to
pursue the idea of
having the
administrators on the one side and the
practitioners on the other side
be
be focused on their
specialties namely the the professionals
who uh who are the practitioners of
whatever the profession is
uh should do that which they know best
which is to
to work on
um
making sure the board works for the
benefit of the public but also the
profession whereas the administrators
will focus on the things that that they
are most experienced at administration
the law and so forth and so on um
that is something that is an ongoing
process with oplc because it is a
relatively new board uh and and those of
us who've been here for a while have
been aware of the fact that there have
been
you know
levels of imperfection with regard to
the initial design of oplc
and
and that has led to
a fair amount of dissatisfaction among
the practitioners
members of the boards but also some
members of the public that
that felt that this
situation doesn't work
all that well
and should be
improved
so that's one of the purposes of this
bill is to set up the committee to study
and make recommendations relative to
funding of the office of professional
licensure and certification as it states
in the analysis
so that's why the bill is important
among other things that the chair has
already spoken to so i just want to
endorse
you see i'm on the bill so
to
also let the public know that we are
working to make the oplc work as well as
possibly can for the
boards it administers and also in the
interest of serving the public so that's
the idea thank you thank you
representative are there any questions
representative schmidt
thank you very much
are there any other members from the
public that wish to testify
representative mcguire
on a purely
technical note i told senator gaida we
would recess the hearing until he shows
up
so plea don't close it just recess it
thank you
seeing no other members i will go into
recess for house bill
so senate bill 313
and
this will need some combing and
a more substantial amendment than i had
provided
so i'm going to be
working on such an amendment
and i would
welcome any any committee member to
point out sections that need need
correction thank you
one o'clock oh until one o'clock okay
okay
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record representative
jeff goalie representing
district hillsborough district 8 which
is manchester's ward 1
and here today to introduce
senate bill 363 fn as amended by the
senate
um
i will be briefed that this just allows
uh
certain members of the retirement system
to purchase non-qualified service time
as group 2 credible service in order to
reduce certain
provisions and requirements for
retirement and i
will let the individual behind me who
followed this through the senate jim
demers speak to the amended version and
the cost that may not be associated with
this and
uh
how it will go as well as i see marty
collin here too but i think jim demers
would be the appropriate person to have
up next seeing senator
de angel hasn't arrived yet
uh yes thank you
find mr jamers if you would fill out a
pink card since we're hoping somebody
will be able to explain to us why this
is worth the bother
thank you madam chairman and i i will
fail out of card i wasn't actually
planning on speaking but
i'm happy to
um so i'm here today on behalf of two
groups the new hampshire police
association and the new hampshire
troopers association
so you're going to hear from both
organizations after me
on
why this bill was introduced so i will
just sort of touch on what the senate
did to the bill so that you understand
what the bill actually does so this bill
is written so that it only applies to
the middle tier
group two
employees so if
you remember 11 years ago
there was a major reform of the
retirement system
and we ended up with a
three tiers of employees so there was
one group that had been in the system
long enough
they stayed at a 20-year retirement
period
and new hires in group one
ended up with a 25-year retirement
period the middle tier is a group of
uh employees who
were hired with the understanding it
would be 20 years but it was increased
and it's a sliding scale so they
went from 20 years to anywhere from
21 years to 25 years
in order to to retire so this deals with
that middle tier group
that were hired
with an understanding it would be 20 but
it was increased to some number between
21 and 25. so the bill before you
allows for that middle tier employees to
be able to purchase years above the
20-year period to get
down to the 20-year period so let me
give you an example if they were hired
20 years
but the system changed them to 25 years
this bill allows them to purchase and
pay the entire expense
of those additional five years
uh to get back down to the 20 years that
they were hired under
um
so
there's there is a feeling that one of
the things that this bill will do will
help
retain some of the employees
uh who have been leaving early and and
you'll hear from one of the people who
would testify behind me that we're
seeing an unusual trend right now as
you've heard this year
in
group two and that is
there are people who are actually
leaving before they even hit the 20 or
25 years
and it's creating a real retention
problem in the area of public safety
so
the feeling is that by giving
some of these individuals if they can
afford it the opportunity to buy down to
the 20 years
they may stay and do the 20 years that
we want
so that's one of the reasons that this
bill exists
and when the senate
when the original version was introduced
it had
two costs to the governments in this uh
in this section so there was a the
fiscal note projected that there would
be a two hundred and ten thousand dollar
cost to local governments
and a thirty thousand dollar cost to
the state
when the senate finance committee worked
on this bill they amended it so that the
language requires the individual would
have to pick up 100 percent of the cost
so there is no longer a cost
to the local governments or state
government in the spill
so the actuary when they figure out what
the years would cost the individual they
will factor in
the individual's expense and the
government's expense and the individual
pays one hundred percent of that so this
bill has no cost to
uh the state or local governments
and it is hard to you know estimate how
many may take advantage of this but we
do believe it's
really going to be small and i will tell
you the reason is because
it's potentially 40 or 45 000
a year
to buy down so you can imagine that's
going to be a fairly small
number of people who have that kind of
financial resources to take advantage of
this so
we think it's a good bill we think
it will help
get some of our employees to stay for
their 20 years and will help deal with
the retention problem that the state
is facing
and
there are people behind me from the two
organizations who would like to speak to
this if they may and i
believe did senator d'alessandro walk in
okay
yes and senator alessandro i think can
speak to what senate finance did with
this bill as well thank you are there
representative grota has a question
thank you
mr demers can you um
help me understand how
this
would retain employees because it seems
like it's a lot of money
forty forty five 000 a year so
why would if someone's going to
why would this prevent someone from
leaving early
so um if a person has let's say
15 years
in the system
uh that means they've got still
potentially another 10 years that they
have to put in and we are actually
seeing people that are are leaving
so if they know they can buy back five
years
so they only will have to do another
five years
and it gets them to the 20 years that
they were actually hired under we think
there are some that would take advantage
of that and stay for the 20 years rather
than leave there are also advantages to
retiring as a full-service employee
rather than retiring and having a vested
benefit that you'll get when you
at a later date if nothing else the
survivor benefit requires you to retire
from a
group two position
are there other questions representative
fellows
thank you madam chair um the estimate
for the cost that you
the estimate for the cost that you
stated 40 to 45
000 are how
how many are they they're buying years
essentially to be added so how many
years
is that equal to and
can people buy like half that amount
yes so
um
the ballpark number of 40 or 45 thousand
000 as i understand it is a per year
cost
so if somebody were to purchase five
years
they have to they would spend 200 and
some odd thousand dollars in order to do
that
if they have five years above the 20
they could buy one
they could buy two they could buy any
amount that gets them lower but they
can't go below the 20 that they were
hired under
so if they had 45 000 and they want to
buy one year they could lower it to 24
years or
if they're in that sliding scale and
they are
they went from 20 to 21 years they could
buy one year to get them to their 20
years so
obviously it's a different decision for
every individual that has to make this
but if someone were to buy all five
years it's going to be
a significant cost
follow-up
um
my
i'm a retired state employee
so my recollection is maybe
15 years ago maybe it was even 20 at one
time group one people could buy
extra
years is this the equivalent of that do
you know
so i do remember there was a period i
don't know if it was quite that long ago
where we opened up a window so that
people could buy down years
uh this is
significantly different
uh because that was an
opportunity for i think almost everybody
in the system this is just aimed at that
middle tier group two
that has this unique situation where
they were you know they were hired
with one assumption but it changed uh
when the reforms went through
follow up
yes the mechanism is the same that they
will have to come up get a calculation
and pony up a lot of money yes that is
true
okay representative schmidt
thank you madam chair so i think your
last remark kind of clarifies my
understanding so we're talking about
somebody would have to they're talking
about five years at the pony up
five times 40
20 000 bucks on the barrel head
at one time
that that's a good question i might
might have to defer to the retirement
system to see if that opportunity a lot
of heads nodding back there with regard
to some of your earlier statements
nodding in agreement
i think some somebody can answer my
question if you can't okay yeah i think
that would be good if i could hold that
one for someone else
all right thank you are there other
questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you excuse me tech
you you talked about buying down isn't
this buying up if somebody's at 18 to
that they buy two to buy either way up
to 20. i don't understand no if they're
they're actually buying down from
let me use an example i think it's the
best way to do it so if
they
are now required to have 25 years to
retire this gives them the ability to
buy down to get toward the 20-year
uh
number that they were hired under so
it's act
i guess there's two ways to look at it
but
i i see it as buying down to get to the
20 years that they were hired under
or
and the glass is half full i'm sure
other questions represent yes follow-up
i i might just say that i know somebody
that took advantage of that group one
buyout it was wonderful it was just
[Laughter]
you have a question
okay thank you thank you senator
d'alessandro
sorry we started without you but it
looked like there was more interest than
i had thought on this
well you have a lot of a lot of interest
in the bill and i apologize for my
lateness i was had another meeting and
uh
it's amazing to me that you started
right on time
all of you get a bonus for the record
i'm senator lou d'allesandro i represent
district 20 manchester awards 3 4 10 11
in the town of goffstown
i come before you as the prime sponsor
of senate bill 363.
i'm here today to introduce or to to
bring to your attention senate bill 363
as amended by the senate
a bill would would allow group two
employees who are in the middle tier
category of the retirement system
to purchase years
to get them back to the 20-year
retirement trigger that they had when
they were hired
we adjusted the retirement system now
you may recall when changes were made to
the state retirement program about 11
years ago
the legislature enacted three tiers of
employees
the first tier is employees who could
retire after 20 years
another tier was the new hires
which had a 25-year retirement and then
there was the middle tier which includes
employees who were hired with the
understanding
that there was a 20-year retirement but
it was increased on a sliding scale
from somewhere between 20 and 25 years
sp 363 deals solely with that middle
tier
group as we all know
retention of our state and local law
enforcement personnel has become a
serious challenge
i indicate that to you in this in this
sense
the state of new hampshire has 2 000
vacancies as we speak
people are retiring in droves
and we are not able to replace them
that's a serious challenge
at the present time i believe we have 60
vacancies at state police
six zero vacancies
recruitment of new hires is extremely
problematic
which is placing added pressure on
retaining the men and women currently in
those jobs
pressure from the private sector
and in some cases outright burnout is
taking its toll i'm sure you all read
the article in the rag today
about the nurses
whose jobs we can't fill
i talked with the superintendent of new
hampshire hospital if we could fill
every vacancy that we have at new
hampshire hospital we would have no
waiting list
i'm sure all of you look at the waiting
list every day for adults and youngsters
it's long
think of it as it relates to the
retirement situation yes thank you
if you could concentrate on this
particular bill i will concentrate on
the bill madame thank you
employees are leaving well before their
25-year retirement trigger
senate bill 363 is designed to help
retain those employees who were bumped
from the 20 to 25 years by giving them
an opportunity to purchase years over
the 20-year period to get them back to
20.
this is not a bill for everyone
because the employees need to purchase
those additional years with their own
money
make that perfectly clear
there's no state or local money involved
in this our amendments at the state
level clearly indicate that all of the
money must come from the individual
because the employee needs to purchase
those additional leaders with their own
money it's costly
but there are some who would take
advantage of it thereby keeping them on
the job for the full 20-year period they
were originally hired for
we're very fortunate in new hampshire to
have an outstanding group of state and
local law enforcement officers who keep
us safe day after day
and we have an obligation to maintain
and retain
this group of dedicated public servants
senate bill 363 is a very small step to
doing just that for a very limited
number of qualifieds qualifications i
hope you can join me in supporting the
bill
the bill as amended as i said takes all
of the financial responsibility and
places it on the individual so there's
no cost to the state of no cost to the
local municipality with that madam chair
i'll conclude my testimony and
be happy to address any queries that
might be presented thank you
representative scitec has one
yeah
senator dale cinder you're on senate
finance right i am
does it strike you as fair your
amendment to make the employee pick what
up 100 percent let me explain by example
yeah i happen to know a salem police
officer
let's use scott as a just as out of the
blue name
who's missed by a few months the 20-year
thing are you going to make him pay 100
because he missed by a couple of months
that just doesn't seem right that
there's not some sliding scale that
there's some cost sharing it just rubs
me the wrong way and i'm asking your
opinion on that well i think that's
that's a great comment when has it ever
been fair representative scitec how we
do things here
in in the house and in the senate uh
when we changed the that when we changed
the retirement system was that fair to
all of the people who weren't vested
did we think about that we were trying
to do something to to
enhance the viability of the system
no no it isn't fair but it's an
opportunity
and the the fairness aspect of it the
way this opportunity can get passed is
if the individual bears all of the
responsibility all of the financial
responsibility that's the way that's the
way it is
and i i think there are there are people
sitting in the seats on the senate side
as you're sitting here that said
for a municipality to pick up any of the
money that was unfair for the state to
pick up any of the of the uh
the financial costs that was not fair so
you know fairness is an in is an issue
that that should be pervasive i mean we
should do everything fairly right i mean
shouldn't we be fair in every decision
we make
but does that happen
no
thank you senator
you're welcome representative allegro
has a question and representative bailey
thank you really this is a comment by
way of clarification if i understood the
question before it was whether it had to
be paid out in a lump sum
or if you look at page one lines nine to
eleven it can be paid in installments
i wanted to get that in while it was
still germaine it also allows
two requests per year so that a person
could
you know buy back a month or a year at a
time if should they so choose
representative bailey thank you madam
chair
thank you senator um
what does the 45 percent that's not
costing anything represent is that like
the present value of all the years of
retirement or between now and 65 or
you say it's not going to cost anything
where does it come from
i think
the gentleman from the retirement system
is here and i think he could address all
of those queries thank you for the
question i'm sure you'll be happy to
address it
any representatives you have a question
now okay anyone else
yes representative june yes good morning
good morning another hello
uh
i heard you talk about 60
vacancy
i would like you to um
explicitly to explain me why we have 60
vacancies
that's a that's a great question
representative judy and i think
we have 2 000 vacancies in state
government why do we have vacancies at
state police because we can't recruit
and retain that's a serious problem in
state government but it's a serious
problem throughout the through the
the entire
employment sector
very difficult to find qualified people
they have to pass the exam they have to
pass the drug test
they have to pass the physical
and people just
are not willing to become troopers at
this point in time just like they're not
willing to become local law enforcement
officers i would say to you that we have
vacancies
in every lawrence law enforcement agency
in our state
these jobs are just very very difficult
to fill at this time at one time there
were thousands who wanted these jobs
that no lo that situation no longer
exists so it's it's a problem
representative judy and we've got to
address it yes
very quickly other questions for the
senator
seeing none thank you very much and i
and i'd like to call
mr carlin for
to answer some questions
and then we'll hear from the other
people
numbers come out much better on paper
than verbally
that's fine
okay
uh thank you madam chair and for the
record marty carlin representing the new
hampshire retirement system
um i know there's a handout working its
way around so i'll uh won't address that
until it gets so everyone but i just
wanted to say the retirement system
doesn't have a position on this bill uh
we're just testifying for informational
purposes only
um
this bill
does uh for the members who are in the
retirement system but not yet tested by
january 1st of 2012
that that cohort of group 2 members have
different minimum age and service
requirements uh for service retirement
based on how many years they had in the
system
as of uh january 1st of 2012.
so the handout shows the the
transition requirements which is how the
statute refers to it in rsa
105. so for instance someone who did not
have 10 years as of uh
january 1st of 12 but had between eight
and ten uh their minimum age and service
went from 45 and 20 to 46 and
with 21 years of service and the benefit
multiplier also decreases
um with each
group uh you know in uh in that middle
middle tier of group 2 members
also on the handout is the the number of
active
members in for police and fire in those
in those slots uh as of last june 30th
you know that number may have gone down
slightly but that's the universe of
people who would be eligible
for
purchasing this service
initially when introduced the bill was
modeled somewhat on the non-qualified
service purchase
language that the representative fellows
referenced that was open in one year
back in 2006
and
members for with no qualifying event
could buy up to five years of additional
service that would go into their pension
calculation when they retired uh that
was repealed by the legislature after a
year
under that old
non-qualified service and under the
original version of senate bill 363 and
i'm talking about the old version just
to clarify some questions people had
about the cost
originally as proposed this the member
would be paying both the employer
contribution rate and the member
contribution rate
you know in effect at the time to buy
each year so the the 45 000 comment came
out just saying if an average group 2
member you know in this age bracket that
close to retirement if they had a
hundred thousand dollar salary
the member and the employer rate
combined is about forty five percent of
pay uh obviously it's it's going to be
dependent on the person's salary um at
that formula
there would there the actuary assume
there'd be a little bit of liability um
created um sort of by the
sort of the prop the principle of
self-selection anybody who would be
advantaged by this probably would take
you know you wouldn't be looking at the
whole universe of people
so the bill was amended now so the
actual full actuarial cost is assessed
individually for each member who wants
to purchase the service so
the the underlying you know the
45 is sort of a proxy but you know even
if if you went in with that flat
charge you know some some members may
have paid more than they should have
under that formula and some would have
paid a little bit less depending on
their salary history how close they are
to retirement how much time they're
buying things like that so all of our
other service purchases um
through the retirement system are based
on an actuarial calculation the
grs makes these calculators for us
basically to run them so we would be
doing uh the same thing for this as we
do for other bills all of our other
services service purchases now
do require a qualifying event uh to buy
the years whether it was you know you
withdrew years before and you can buy
those back or military service things
like that there is no airtime free
service you can just buy um you know and
again this this set is limited to this
this cohort of group two so somebody
you know in the who is now in the
minimum age and minimum service of 46
and 21 can buy one year somebody who was
in the you know age minimum age of 48
minimum service of 23 can buy up to
three years um
so you know that's that's how how it is
set up um the bill the way it's written
set does say not less than one year so
uh we we don't read it to allow you know
buying months you're you're buying whole
years you know based on the language
that um we're looking at in the bill
so the first
set of group two members affected by
this the the 46 and 21 the the you know
the the person who started on
you know january 2nd 2002
um you know would have had their uh
would have had their 20 years this year
to retire they'd be eligible beginning
uh early next year for that and then
so on and so forth so that you know uh
and one one thing about the bill as well
is
uh on the on the handout you see how the
benefit multiplier that's a percentage
of the afc that you accrue for each year
of service
um
goes down um
the server the purchase time uh is at
the two and a half percent multiplier
which was the the original tier of group
two so it's a slightly larger you know
annual multiplier for that
um you know with that i'd be glad to
answer any questions anyone may have
thank you representative lekkis has a
question thank you um
a couple things one is um
you know from the retirement systems
point of view do you agree that
there will be
no cost to the employers or the state
including you know the uh benefits to
retiring as a fully invested person that
was mentioned by the chair
other than i noticed there was a startup
cost of around 40k is that it yes okay
that's to build the calculator and to
program the the pension system itself
follow-up
and i notice in your handout um
it says this would not accelerate their
eligibility for um retirement health
care
um so if they
bought down a couple of years
then
you know they'd be on there would they
be on their own for whatever they can do
for health care for those two years
until the retiree healthcare picked in
is that part of this
the the for for state retirees um that
that goes you know through admin
services and there's a whole different
statute when you started and when you
became eligible so so admin services on
the original bill in the senate did
raise concerns about would this have any
implications for the the health care
program and there was a section that was
taken out of this bill so um you know
and again we don't administer that but
that that's the reason so
if
i i'm not sure how many years someone
needed in group two to qualify for the
insurance before but it this is only
specific to the retirement system i
believe it it's 20 years at this point
it
it was 10 years for a while but i
believe it's 20 right now
and quit one quick follow follow up and
that is um
i know you can't predict this but
i mean do you think it's likely that
enough people are going to take
advantage of this to make you know this
whole thing including the startup cost
worthwhile i'm a little skeptical um
yeah it's it's really hard to say
because it's a new
type of service purchase for a for a
specific group of people
so um you know
talking to some of the to the uh folks
who were were working on the bill
you know and also you know on the
actuary we're anywhere you know five
percent or less of the total population
maybe closer to two or three is what
people are saying and they they i think
they can probably speak to their
groups that they represent what they're
hearing um so so we do expect it to be
somewhat of a niche
piece but you know if it's available for
people who
have the means in the desire to take
advantage of it you know we don't have a
trouble administering it
thank you representative allegro thank
you i um on merits or i should say on
the issue of fairness i think
it stands alone on its own merit
but in terms of recruitment and
retention i'm not clear on a couple
things maybe you can answer my question
or someone else can
in terms of recruitment
anyone who hasn't been hired yet is not
going to be eligible for this program
correct so it really won't impact
recruitment
yeah correct this is only for the people
who are in the system
and on in terms of uh retention
anybody who's indicated a desire to buy
one year
is going to be gone in one year now but
i understand am i understanding that
correctly or
they can buy the year at any time
and so they may buy it immediately or
when they can afford it or
something before
very shortly before they retire okay but
technically they they can buy it when
they're in there for 11 years saying i
you know i don't think i want to do this
for another nine or whatever and they
could buy a year or two early okay thank
you
other questions
representative o'brien and then fellow
uh thank you madam chair uh mr collins
this may be just a wee bit out of your
league with the nhrs but basically
thinking on a municipal end where you
have a long-term employee he goes
through some contractual raises perhaps
promotions and he's pretty much at the
top of some game
so if this you know kind of helps people
at that high end
go and and you say with retention there
could be a cost factor to the you know
municipalities or the political
subdivisions and hiring people at the
lower grade and starting pay
uh to help out and uh that could be a
you know a hidden benefit of this with
the uh local taxpayers i'll i'll concur
with your initial statement that it's a
little bit out of my league
representative yeah i i kind of figured
that thank you mr congress
okay thank you um
i have a question you said that it might
be two or three percent
that it's just a you know a
very a guess well with
with eighteen hundred people
two or three percent is like twenty or
thirty
i think um or two or three depends
let me get my fractions right 18
18 yeah so 20 maybe 20 people so it's
costing us a couple of thousand each
to uh to administer this
so we'll i will be uh
looking at the
or listening to the people who are
speaking on the next i think the uptake
certainly could be higher there's really
no way of predicting it's like if the
bill passes and people start getting
estimates and deciding it makes sense
for them or not then that's the only
time we'll know is after that starts
happening
thank you very much are there other
questions represent fellows yes sorry
so um i i have two questions
um i'm looking at the bill and starting
on line nine
you could just explain to me exactly
what's going on it's it says
they're not granted
the service
until it's
fully paid for and something about the
money going into the members annuity
savings fund and my second question is
if they buy the
the extra credit
today well not today but when the bill
first is approved
compared to buying it the same amount
two or three years later is the cost
going to go up the longer they wait
so that's two questions of this annuity
when when does it take
when do they actually have something to
hold on to
and
what is the issue with the annuity
savings fund and will it cost more if
they delay three questions i'll take the
first quest the the annuity savings fund
address that first
basically when members contribute um you
know they're in their individual
contributions plus any statutory
interest credited to them is in in the
members individual account and all of
those individual individual accounts are
part of the member annuity savings fund
so in other words if someone bought a
year of service and and you know paid us
another you know forty to fifty thousand
dollars to buy that year that's gonna be
credited to their individual
contributions you know so so it doesn't
you know if they chose to cash out when
they terminated they could take all that
they get that money back if they passed
away they'll if they didn't have a you
know a designated beneficiary for
benefit that that would be paid back to
the beneficiary so it's basically it's
still the members money when it's in the
member in the member annuity savings
fund so that's just sort of you know the
way that works it and in terms of the
cost
um
i think in general terms you know the
higher your salary the closer you are to
retirement you know the cost is is
generally speaking going to be larger
than somebody you know somebody who's
you know
44 versus you know 34 you know they're
probably making less you know they're
farther away from retirement you know so
the the actual cost could be different
for that person you know but there's a
lot of different factors it's also you
know what their salary is um you know
what the projected salaries are how long
out you know are they that they have to
go to retirement but generally speaking
yes it's probably cheaper to buy it
sooner than right at the end but um
you know assumptions do change so if if
you know if we were to change the actual
assumptions if the assume rate of return
went up or down that would have an
impact on the actuarial cost of this you
know we're not looking at that for
another couple of years at the earliest
but you know so so there are sort of
variables in the actuarial world that
could play into it but you know
generally speaking yeah you know
tends to be less expensive to buy it
earlier in your career
thank you representative grota
whether one person
takes advantage of this or 20 people the
cost to the new hampshire retirement
system would be 40 000 is that correct
yeah that's that's a that's a high-end
estimate but yes yeah once the software
is set up to accommodate it you know it
doesn't matter how many
may i have a follow-up thank you
so let's say someone
has nine years to go
and they think that they want to work
for another seven
they could at the time at time zero
start
this extra payment through installments
into the new hampshire retirement system
so they could retire two years early if
they were indeed supposed to work until
20 years
is that correct the bill does allow for
installment payments um yes i you know
if the bill passes i i would assume the
the board would work with staff to come
up with some written policy on that we
don't we don't have one now because it
doesn't exist but you know that that is
would yeah if if you weren't going to be
you weren't eligible to retire for five
years you may be able to pay that off
in pieces but again that that'll be the
board's final decision but the bill does
allow that to be set up that way
okay and last follow-up so i just want
to make sure that because you know as
things as you approach retirement
sometimes things change
and you decide that let's say you've
paid for the for the two years and you
decide you want to stay a longer
how flexible is this program going to be
for those employees
once you've purchased the service you
have the service okay and you know that
you yeah there's there's no
i changed my mind can i get a refund i
mean you bought the service that's in
your record you know your pension will
be based on it you know and i had heard
anecdotally with the five years there
were some people who ended up going out
on a disability benefit so buying the
five years was kind of pointless for
them
but you know that's
you know there are risks in life with
everything um you know but this is
buying yourself an earlier retirement
age you know in a more years of service
in which to base the benefit so just for
clarification i just want to make sure
i'm not asking for a refund but let's
say that employee they let's say they
pay for the two years that two years is
in the bank is in their bank and they
can work a little longer if they wish to
oh absolutely you could but you could
buy it but you don't have to go out at
the minimum i mean if you bought it and
then
circumstances change and you want to
work another five or even 10 years you
know yes it doesn't force anybody to
leave early if they bought the time they
just had more time when they did finally
terminate okay thank you so much
other questions
all right thank you very much mr carlin
i'd like to call claudia cass
thank you madam chair and thank all of
you for being here
i'll try and keep it brief i just wanted
to clear up a couple of things
um obviously i'm not super versed on
this doesn't sound like anybody really
is
the exact impact of it
but as i understand it i know the
question was posed about fairness and
i'm glad it was posed because no it's
not feel fair
11 years ago when they changed our
pension system and
affected people like myself who had
about six years of service in at that
time
didn't feel fair because this bill never
passed this was christmas tree onto the
omnibus spending bill and it effectively
sentenced me to three years in prison
so now that did not feel fair
this does a little something to help
correct that
i didn't start my career in state
service i worked in the private sector
for many years and i came to work for
the state when i was 35 years old
with the amendments with the changes
they made to this i can't retire until
i'm 58 years old
i work every day in a prison i'm
outnumbered usually around 150 to 1.
just the other day
about 2-3 days ago i was working in the
kitchen
and i stumbled across
a very large gentleman probably over six
feet tall easily over six feet tall and
several hundred pounds
i'm about to like k2
i was by myself in the kitchen core
and i needed to secure the evidence and
secure the inmate
that's what i do for a living
i have a hard enough time doing it at 50
and at 58 i can't
i don't think that i can do this
for eight more years i just don't think
i can
maybe maybe five
that was my original deals i could
retire at 55 and this is hard enough to
do at 55. just to be here today to
testify i had to refuse force that's
because
i worked overtime yesterday and i was
forced again this morning and the
prisons running short
it's very taxing the job that i do is
exhausting
mr scitec i know your wife very well
she sat on the parole board so she knows
me i let her in every single day and
what's interesting about that i work
third shift
i know her because i worked overtime
every day in that particular post i
don't do that anymore i walk the tears
16 hours a day and i am amongst the
inmates usually alone with a radio that
often doesn't work
it's scary
i don't want to do this for eight more
years i don't really want to do it for
five but at least it puts the carrot
closer
and as he kind of pointed out there or
she did as far as vested for benefits
that if i don't make it
my heirs would only get the uh monies
that were put into my account my
individual account
that's just the way our pension system
set up
so my family would get the monies that i
put in and that's it with uh some
statutory interest
so
is it fair note
is it cost prohibitive perhaps
but what is a year of your life worth
is it worth 40 000 it is to me
my husband's terminal i want to be with
my grandkids that's a year of my life
it's about as much as my daughter's
spending to buy her condo right now so
no it doesn't feel super fair but it's
an opportunity that i might be able to
make it to retirement
and i want to make it to retirement
i'm not going to lie
so i'm glad for people like yourself
that
got to buy your years of service
that were much cheaper military times
cheaper this is expensive
but it's a matter of worth and it's you
know worth it to me it changes my
calculation so that when i do retire
my
my pension would be a little higher
and that's obviously important because
inflation's a reality and i also get
penalized with the
windfall tax so my social security is
penalized as well
so
by being able to even recover just a
little bit of what was taken away from
us in that omnibus spending bill
it it's something it's i'm not going to
pretend it's not something it is
thank you very much are there any
questions representative schuett
thank you madam chair
first off thank you very much for your
service
um i just curious i sounding
from what you just said
it sounds like
you would be willing to say take a
second mortgage on your house
in order to be able to afford this and
you feel that would be a better benefit
for you
i did like the fact that it allows
make to make payments so that i could
maybe spread this over the rest of my
career and i think that would affect
retention because
obviously if you know i'm spending a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars
i'm probably going to have to work a few
more years you know to make those types
of payments
but that would make it you know so i
could still retire at 55
and uh you know that's important to me
and that changes the calculation because
i was looking at leaving state service
to start undoing my windfall tax
um so it there's a there's a few
benefits for me in that
hey thank you representative
can i tell donna you said hello could
you please i'm sorry i wasn't invited to
the retirement party i would have been
there
oh well
anna aren't you yes representative judy
yes
good morning ma'am good morning um
correct me if i want because i heard you
say the radio is broken
pardon me the radio is broken and then
you work with one quite often our radios
fail to function we have a problem with
the equipment it's uh
i guess old the batteries just tend not
to work and we have to share them so
they don't indicate when they're dying
so you find out this was the second time
that i was in the kitchen core and i
caught an offender with drugs and the
first time my radio did fail to function
as i called for the response team they
couldn't hear me because when you key
your radio it beeps
and uh so they couldn't hear my
transmission and didn't know where i was
so i was left alone to wrestle the
inmate but i was a younger girl at the
time
this time i was looking he's a big guy
i i wanted to be like oh i don't see
that and walk away but that's not what
you pay me for and i did my job
fortunately it worked out very well wow
yes and my radio did work by the way so
back up okay
i'm really sorry about that
are there other questions
and thank you very much for taking the
time to share this with us thank you all
for your service
joseph ebert
good morning members of the committee
madam chairman
i'm madam chairwoman uh my name is
joseph ebert it's eb ert
i'm a major with the state police i
oversee our investigative services
bureau
i think it's very important for you to
know that
so you have an understanding of why the
this bill is so important to me but i
also think it's important for you to
know that i've i've taken time uh off
today to be here uh i'm not here
representing the division of state
police i'm here representing myself uh
but if not given the context it would i
would certainly question why this
individual was sitting before me
so
there's been
numerous things that have been covered
before uh my testimony so i will
try and keep this as as condensed as
possible but i'm i'm clearly very
passionate about this this particular
build
i wanted to start by just saying to you
i i began
my career my professional career after
graduate school i i went to work for a
medical software company i was living in
the metro boston area i felt like this
was a uh this was a way to repay my my
loans it certainly was
but i felt unfulfilled with the
the position it just it didn't seem to
uh it didn't seem to fulfill
what i thought was a noble profession
nothing wrong with it just uh i felt
like okay there's something bigger uh
something different that i can do
so i began the process to become a new
hampshire state trooper
i am incredibly glad grateful uh and
humbled to have been
part of the division for
nearly 20 years now
and i left my job in medical software i
came home to the state of new hampshire
and i did that based on a number of
different factors i did that because i
felt
most importantly like this was a noble
profession that i could make an impact
on not just my community but my state my
home state
i also did that in part on the notion as
i sat down and they
gave you gave me my benefits package at
the time they handed me a blue trifold
that said this is your retirement in 20
years from now these are the benefits
that you'll get
and i certainly took that into
consideration it wasn't the only uh
factor but i certainly took that into
consideration that okay in 20 years i
can start another career
i'll be 45 years old i'm still very
young i can i can move on and i can uh i
can start anew
so uh
with that in mind i wanted to
put in perspective where i was
when the changes took place i had uh
nine years and five months on so i fell
about seven months short of the uh of
the marker of being vested in the in the
system um
and that was uh
that was really a difficult time for me
um
i don't want to rehash that there was
certainly lots of testimony that
happened at the time that people were
very passionate about it i was very
passionate about it
but what i accepted was
although i i didn't agree with it i
understood the need to make the system
uh foundationally sound nobody cares
about the retirement system being
financially sound more than those of us
who are in it
so i didn't agree with the way that it
took place but i did on degree uh i did
understand the reason that it was
happening
so often times i i speak to people and
they they ask me like what is the big
deal like
you're you're extended one year why is
this uh an issue for you like just do
one more year uh
and i try and explain to them the
difference between
my profession what you've heard from uh
a member of the correctional department
and what you'll hear from other people
who come behind me uh but my profession
is not a nine-to-five job uh it is uh
much different from that i was
indoctrinated into that my first year in
the state police where i was required to
live in the barracks uh and move around
the state uh and i enjoyed that it was a
tremendous experience
but from 2004 when i entered into the
crisis negotiation unit and in 2008 when
i entered into our major crime unit
until present day i've been on call 365
days a year
seven days a week and uh that's part of
the responsibility of the job so my
phone rings in my current position
overseeing the homicide unit the
narcotics unit uh the cyber
investigations unit uh our terrorism and
intelligence unit
my phone rings all night long all night
long all day long uh i've accepted as is
my family that when i'm at uh funerals
weddings uh holidays vacations that when
that phone rings it's my responsibility
to pick up the phone and to ensure that
if i have to respond i do and if i can
deal with what needs to be dealt with
over the phone that i do that and i step
away from whatever i'm doing
and i do that because the decisions that
are going on are life and death
decisions both for members of the public
but also for uh my fellow troopers so i
take that very seriously um
i won't bore you with uh 20 years of
what took place in my career
but i will tell you that i've had
occasion to be exposed to hiv a very
difficult conversation to have with your
spouse when
you're trying to start a family and
you're you're exposed to a blood-borne
pathogen and as much as i want to say
you know it was a unique situation it
wasn't i was on the midnight shift with
six other troopers at the time all six
of them had been exposed to either hiv
hepatitis or some other blood-borne
pathogen
from biting spitting fighting exchange
of blood uh these are the things that uh
that happen uh
so
uh i've talked um
in the senate about this as well um
and i would share with you that i've
dealt uh because of my career path i've
dealt with more dead people dead
children than i can
even remember
and i
i will tell you that each one of those
individuals that you have contact with
each deceased individual and their
family
leaving and double mark
on you as a person
um and lastly you know i would just
point out over the uh the 20-year period
i've unfortunately had the occasion to
to bury some of my friends
those individuals who
in the line of duty have given their
life
and unfortunately
in some circumstances have taken their
life
it's a difficult difficult career
but what i want to point out to this
committee what i really want to get
across to you is i've never once asked
for sympathy for the experiences that
i've had
because i truly believe that i knew
going in the front door i knew what what
i said i would do
i knew that these things could happen
and now at 25 years old i may not have
envisioned that they would all happen uh
but i knew the dangers of the job
and i accepted that
and
you know it
the retirement changes were so difficult
for me because i felt like on those days
when it was really really difficult when
i was being asked to do something that i
knew
was either going to put my life at great
risk or put
you know my mental health at great risk
i knew it didn't matter i said i would
do it so i would do it
and i felt like when the retirement
changes whether right or wrong
came through
when it became the really really tough
day for the state
instead of the state bearing that burden
a lot of it was shifted to the employee
uh and again i understand why it was
done
but it was it was difficult for me to
internalize
so uh
i you know one of the things that uh i
wanted to make sure that i uh pointed
out is i i think that this bill strikes
a a real balance between uh the goal of
keeping the system healthy and keeping
the mental health uh
of the employee healthy you've heard an
awful lot about the fact that this is a
retention bill i truly believe that it
is for those troopers who are staring
down nine more years who have the
possibility of buying four and shrinking
that this is truly a retention bill for
them
for myself at the other end of the
spectrum
this isn't necessarily a a retention
bill for me
this is an opportunity to to leave and
be with my family
i leave you with this that i
for the last 20 years i've prided myself
on putting the state of new hampshire
and the division of state police first
whenever
the phone rang i went and sometimes
begrudgingly
but i always went i never turned away
from the duty that i said that i would
do
but i would ask that you consider
passage of this bill uh and return to me
the ability to put my family first uh
starting on august 2nd of this coming
year this year
august 2nd of 2022
so i thank you so much for the
opportunity to
speak this morning and i am more than
willing to answer any questions that you
might have
thank you very much are there any
questions
no i think you covered everything very
nicely thank you very much thank you
again members of the committee of
managing chairwoman
uh frank swirlo
good morning
uh my name is frank swerko it's not the
first time i've heard willow either but
uh
i appreciate the opportunity to speak on
this issue
i am a parole and probation officer for
the state of new hampshire i currently
work out of the manchester district
office
where there are 12
officers and one chief we all carry
about 100 cases 100 individuals that we
supervise
don't ask me how we supervise that many
people but
you may not like the answer we pull it
off
i'm also
the president of the probation parallel
officers association and i'm on the
board of directors for the new hampshire
police association
i have grown up
around law enforcement my father
uncles uh my brother is a current uh my
little brother is on the manchester fire
department currently he is also in the
middle group as am i and many other
people i work with
uh so you can say it runs in the blood
uh when it comes to my family
we obviously have a lot of friends in
law enforcement i've grown up growing up
with them and one thing i've noticed
over the years is that people came from
all over the country to come work in new
hampshire arizona new york florida texas
i've known people from all over the
country who came and worked in new
hampshire i believe that's largely
because of the benefits new hampshire
offered in the retirement system
you don't see that anymore i think that
the instability of the retirement system
and the unpredictability has affected
uh people coming to work in new
hampshire
and you talk about
recruitment i think that's a large part
of it i know that's one of the reasons i
wanted to come into this line of line of
work i'm not sure that i would want to
if i knew then what i knew now i'm not
sure that i would want to be in this
line of work because some of the things
i've had to deal with and my family's
dealt with in their career but
i do think recruitment retention is is
is a main part of this
of this build
uh i was still young i had about five or
six years on the job when when all these
conversations initially took place and
the change took place in 2012
i wasn't as involved as i should have
been or would have liked to have been
but i had i was young and dumb and had a
young family you know my my first
marriage was deteriorating because of
the hours that i was working at the
prison largely not not all but largely
because of the crazy schedule i think we
all know about the
issues at the prison
sorry
but in recent years i've educated myself
more and more about the issues that led
up to that and the possible reasons for
the proposed changes and what eventually
changed and
i i can say that i understand them
i i almost i almost understand them um
and then one thing always strikes me uh
something that i deal with in my role as
a
as a president of a union and that is
what's right is right when you deal with
any issue or any
take a position or any fight you you
look at it is this a reasonable
situation is is what we're looking for
reasonable and is it right and i believe
this bill is right it doesn't correct
um what many of us feel is was the wrong
done to us in 2012 but i think it's a
step in the right direction for
a lot of um reasons which
have already been spoken to today so
um with that i leave you i i do want to
mention that i think new hampshire's
been
lucky enough not to be in some of these
national headlines over the last few
years and i think the recruitment that
people that have been attracted to new
hampshire
law enforcement specifically is a large
reason for that so
uh thank you for the time and i'll take
any questions
thank you for your testimony are there
i don't see any thank you again mr
regassa
can you hear me good morning man i'm
chair and good morning everyone
uh
i'm here to
take your name again yes my name is
safio ragasa last name spell
r-a-g-a-s-s-a
and you pronounced it correctly madam
chair
i couldn't read the first name but the
last one was obvious
that's all right
um
currently i'm the president of uh chief
prohibition parole officers in state of
new hampshire
um
i am also a
taxpayer and resident of this state and
i have done so for a little over 20
years now
the question before us is about this
bill
do i support this bill
yes i support this bill
do i support it because this is the best
bill
that would restore what was taken away
from the hard and dedicated
first responders
no really as representative scitec
uh stated that is this bill even a fair
bill
would this give the ability for members
equally to purchase the time the answer
is no
but this bill is better than
what is the current practice in this
state
i am similarly to the police officer a
representative sciatic mentioned
i was two months away from my
being vested when they changed this law
so when we talk about fairness is this
fair to ask the member to pay 40 000
the question will be also was it fair to
change the law
uh against individuals who are promised
to do something
who are told you can retire at the age
of 45 or 20
but then midway through their career
change it and retroactively
affect those members
that wasn't fair either so we are we're
caught in
that dilemma
yes it would give us the opportunity to
buy the time
it will also help with retention
of those who would leave otherwise and
i'll tell you i have members who have
currently served the state for 17 or 16
years and looking into some form of
private sector job which gives them the
flexibility to work from home from
remote area and often time i hear why
would you do it you already have 16
years
and the answer i always get is that
no
the other years have really
contributed to this thrust level that i
have about the system
so would you serve us a retention yeah
it would at least those people say okay
i can at least retire in a time frame i
was promised even though
even though it's going to be costly for
me
even though the individual will bear the
responsibility of paying hundred percent
of that contribution
but at least that person can retire as
promised that's the only benefit
so
for many reasons uh that i would support
this bill
i'm not happy about it
the fact the cost
that is from the employee hundred
percent
is
another challenge for us
and
but i have to say that it is better than
what the current practice is and that's
why we you all heard it from us you
heard from the correctional officer the
police officer the probation officer
you're hearing it from me
we're not highly enthusiastic about this
bill wow it's going to fix everything
but it is it will be different than
what the current practice is which lifts
a bad eastern or mouse
so that's all i have okay thank you very
much for your testimony are there any
questions
i think we're you think you covered it
very well all right
thank you very much
michael kija
and i do hope you don't plan to take
full 10 minutes
thank you madam chair
my name is michael gea geha i'm
president of the new hampshire police
association i'm also a detective with
the salem new hampshire police
department
you have heard several times this
session that the state of new hampshire
and just about every city and town are
facing serious employment challenges in
the public safety area
especially law enforcement
state police now have 61 unfilled
openings and local communities are
finding the applicant pool to be
extremely tight
with that cities and towns are competing
against each other for not only new
hires but in retaining existing
personnel
competition from the private sector and
in some cases outright burnout are
adding to this very concerning public
safety problem
we are now experiencing an out of the
ordinary trend with a growing number of
employees who are leaving before they
even reach their 20 or 25 years
that is something none of us could have
contemplated just a couple of years ago
sb 363 is a small tool that will help in
retaining some individuals who might be
thinking about leaving early
and quite frankly the economics makes
sense local communities spend on average
approximately fifty to seventy five
thousand dollars to train and equip each
new police officer
each time one leaves the new hire
training costs hit the local budget
i realize this bill isn't for everyone
but for the small number in the middle
tier who have the money to buy years to
get them down to the 20th period
when they were hired under
this may help keep them in in their
position longer rather than leaving
early this bill was amended in the
senate to clarify that the entire cost
would be covered by employees there is
no cost to the state or local
communities
we need to do everything possible to
encourage individuals to work their full
pre-retirement term
and we need to do everything possible to
make sure the citizens of the state
receive the law enforcement protection
that is needed
as well as they deserve
this bill will help help accomplish
those goals i was hired back in 1999 and
i get asked this question all the time
why are you still here and my answer is
always the same i love my job
so on behalf of new hampshire police
association we urge you to pass sb 363.
thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions
i don't see any
so thank you for your testimony thank
you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
on senate bill 363
i just have a question ma'am share uh a
police officer just testified
has a
a uh
he was reading something
can you hand that can you give us your
written document
okay thank you
there is no other person testifying i'm
going to close the hearing
and open the hearing on senate bill 438
no one has yet signed up to testify but
i see the prime sponsor senator sherman
he's
thank you
no give it to our clerk
senator oh you do have written testimony
yes sir senator sherman
governor
yes
that's what the bill says
you buy
it specifically says you may buy up a
year and that's on the toward the bottom
of page one
uh representative fellows
my friend who bought into their group
one had to do it on the spot
anyway
yes senator
ready
please proceed okay thank you very much
madam chair for the record my name is
senator tom sherman district 24
comprising 11 towns over on the seacoast
i am here to introduce sb 438 fn local
establishing state and local procurement
policies intended to promote the use of
american materials
we have four major steel steel
fabricating plants in new hampshire one
of these is in my district in greenland
novel ironworks i had a tour of this
complex followed by a discussion with
holly navaletsky the owner and ceo of
the company
these companies are responsible
employers with dedicated employees but
they are competing with foreign
manufacturers for work in new hampshire
and across new england i learned that
the playing field is anything but level
with many of these foreign producers due
to government support favorable tax
structures or and or exchange rates able
to offer their products at such low
prices that our own in-state
manufacturers cannot compete
our granite state fabricators have
compelling stories of being unable to
bid for contracts even in the cities and
municipalities in which their factories
are located
the concept behind this bill is not new
it is standard of practice for federal
highway projects
recently there's been a movement in
state legislatures across the country to
level the playing field to support
american-made products by ensuring that
they are utilized in these publicly in
publicly funded projects
one critical lesson we have learned
during covitt is the price of
outsourcing manufacturing behind beyond
us borders
whether it was ppe plexiglas ventilators
or other products essential to
protecting the health of americans
during the pandemic
lack of availability within the united
states created significant barriers to
access during the crisis
and persistent broad foreign supply
chain shortages continue to drive up
consumer prices here at home
supporting u.s based manufacturing as
anticipated in this bill ensures that
there will be a high quality production
on american soil supports local job
growth with excellent wages and benefits
and represents a direct investment in
our own businesses and economy
while some may claim that this might
drive up costs at least 21 states have
laws that require government preference
for american-made materials and products
38 states have in-state procurement
preferences for manufacturers and
specifically every one dollar spent on
domestic fabricated steel has generated
about 1.50 in subsequent economic
activity
similar legislation passed recently in
new jersey and did so unanimously in the
texas legislature
it's now under consideration
massachusetts and interestingly
countries that represent current foreign
sources of similar products allow their
regional governments and provinces to
pass the exact same type of guard rails
contemplated in this bill to support
their own local industries
this is not simply a matter of new
hampshire jobs and businesses it has
grown in my estimation to be an issue of
national economic security and
independence
in the senate after introducing sb 438
and hearing the testimony from the
contractors and from the municipal
association as well as many others we
sat down as a group
and this was attended by the chair
um and
amended the bill to what you have before
you today all stakeholders have signed
off on this bill and it's much better
than what i introduced which is so often
the case here in the legislature
we refined the definition to be more
specific we put in place metrics for
implementation as well as a waiver
process and we made sure that compliance
and accountability had some teeth using
standard language from the department of
revenue administration for similar
processes
while allowing for appropriate exemption
this bill
requires the state to reinvest taxpayer
dollars in our own local regional and
statewide economies
please join me in supporting the
strategic investment in new hampshire
businesses employees and communities by
voting ought to pass on this buy
american bill sb 438 thank you so much
happy to take questions
thank you are there questions
representative marsh and then shut
uh thank you senator for coming to us
today as you know i grew up in the city
of pittsburgh and did a little studying
of the steel industry like most people
growing up in the city of pittsburgh did
do we actually have smelters in new
hampshire or are they just still
fabricators
um that's beyond my pay grade but i
there are people here from all of the
fabricator companies and they can answer
that
question sorry excellent
can i ask another question madam chair
follow-up follow-up question did uh the
senate receive any input from the
canadian consul general and fabricating
this bill
nice nice choice of words um
the bill was fabricate i
do believe i'd have to go back and look
at the committee report but i do think
the canadian
there was uh someone testifying on
behalf of canada there thank you
representative
thank you madam chair thank you senator
um i see that it this bill reef
refers to
contracts involving at least one million
dollars
does the state have many contracts lower
than that or how many
what's the i would say yes the state has
numerous small contracts and that's
this was really sort of to set a
threshold where this would kick in
and in general i
this might be a better
question for the fabricators but
when you're talking about large steel
fabrication projects you're
you're typically up in to much more
expensive projects
other questions representative allegro
thank you is there a guardrail in the
bill to keep contractors from
the less than honorable
practice of breaking a two million
dollar contract into two one million
dollar contracts
um i believe that's beyond the scope of
this bill
okay so the answer is no
no thank you
are there any other questions
thank you senator thank you very much
i see that all the steel fabricators who
expect to benefit from this bill are
here
is there anyone who wished to testify
who is not a steel an iron fabricator
all right seeing none thank you i'll
call adam fallon
paperwork
thank you so much
good morning thank you for having me
this morning
i'm a little out of order
but that's okay
i'll i'll start off and you'll certainly
hear from the fabricators involved i
come at things from a slightly different
perspective i'd actually be someone who
would work with the fabricators
downstream as i work with usi
so i'm actually an insurance broker my
background to give you a little
perspective is uh i spent 10 years in
the welding industry working for lincoln
electric so i actually had the pleasure
of working with many of these companies
and many others throughout all of new
england of varying sizes for the last
six years i've spent my time in the risk
management world and insurance
so although my role has changed clearly
uh it's always been a part of me in that
welding world i still have my welding
gear i'm still certainly capable of it
and it's a industry that i certainly
enjoy working with
ultimately i'm in support of this bill
because i want to see our publicly
available dollars for projects like this
to stay in new hampshire and to be
invested in the local communities
we all know that the silver tsunami is a
real thing and the next generation needs
local jobs part of my job uh when i was
at lincoln electric in the welding world
was working with groups like uh sico
school of technology on which i was on
the board i live in exeter so it's just
down the road from me i also worked with
other technical programs like white
mountain community college and
manchester community college in fact
actually ran the skills usa competition
for a few years in new hampshire as well
so i've had the benefit and joy of
seeing some of these students and just
seeing how much it means to them and to
have
jobs available to them when they get out
of these schools and have a place to go
that is local to the communities that
they live in whether that's in greenland
berlin or anywhere in between
in my the another piece of this puzzle
is that as an insurance broker i look at
things from a different perspective
when steel fabricators have more work
and they have more employees that leads
to
more things like workers comp premiums
and what does that mean for us that
means we can hire more people for our
own industry that's account managers
producers
lost control personnel etc it also leads
to help us gather some additional
analytical information so then we can
use that to further our research within
the industry and hopefully make it safer
for those who are participating
so needless to say
i thank you all for your time
thank you very much are there any
questions
all right seeing none thank you thank
you
stephen chasick
if anyone else has testimony
written testimony to provide please give
it to us now if you don't mind
good morning
i'd first like to thank you for the
opportunity to testify in support of
bill 438
my name is stephen chasey and i'm the
owner and president of vessel chasey
steele in hudson new hampshire
sl chasey steele hasn't been has been in
business for 32 years we currently have
over 170 employees
most of our employees live in new
hampshire many grew up in new hampshire
they pay real estate taxes in new
hampshire and have graduated from new
hampshire schools
now they're raising their own children
in new hampshire or sending them to new
hampshire schools
i'm here to testify from my own personal
experience
s.l chasey steele and my fellow new
hampshire and new england-based steel
fabricators see more structural steel
buildings being fabricated outside the
united states
new hampshire state city and town tax
dollars that are being used to fund
municipal construction projects are
going to foreign sale fabrication
companies instead of local new hampshire
based companies like ours
i see local schools that our employees
children's attend being fabricated
outside of this country
these children never had the opportunity
to say to their classmates my father and
my mother built our school
when in fact their parents tax dollars
paid for the school
through flawed procurement laws our
state city and town tax dollars money
meant to strengthen new hampshire's
economy leaves the country when foreign
steel fabricators awarded work on the
public construction projects
in effect
we are bolstering another country's
economy instead of our own
the situation has gotten to a point
where it's almost a waste of resources
to even bid on these projects
foreign steel fabrication companies are
often financially subsidized by their
governments and or
enjoy favorable currency exchanges with
the united states enabling them to
repeatedly undercut american fabricators
in the bidding process
when foreign fabricated steel is
purchased there is no economic benefit
to the domestic economy
as i'm sure you know local spending has
significant economic impacts on local
and regional economies because of the
multiplier effect local spending is
multiplied multiplier
impacts on employment income and tax
revenues
simply stated for every dollar spent on
domestic fabricated steel 1.50 is
generated in domestic
economic activity for every dollar spent
on foreign fabricated steel
zero dollars are generated in domestic
economic activity
income associated with steel fabrication
will will result in income to local
residents this income will be spent on
local goods and services such as
restaurants lodging hardware stores and
other local industries if these public
construction projects awarded to foreign
firms then the economic benefits will be
demonstrated in the foreign economies
thus resulting in zero economic stimulus
to local regional and national economies
we need you our state government to
support senate bill 438 and keep our tax
dollars here in new hampshire i thank
you for your time and consideration of
this matter
thank you are there any questions
representative psychic
mr chassis you are
i don't know it's
i don't know what's going on
how can
i when i saw this i thought you're
smelting
you know taking ore and making
the pictures of the blast furnaces
you're talking about fabrication correct
well how does a foreign company come in
and do fabrication
i understand that they fabricate in a
different country they truck it
to new hampshire
and then they hire or they have their
own erectors that erect a steel in new
hampshire so the steel is actually
fabricated in a different country by
that companies or that company
that is in that country their employees
not our employees they ship it to the
united states
and then they install it
salem just built
a hospital uh oh i can't think of the
name right mass general has built
something there and i saw that all the
steel framework
amazing how the steel is holding that
whole building up
who where did that how did that how
would this affect
that's private but assuming it was a
government thing
how
this you buy the same steel from
somebody direct to build the thing i i
i'm really at a loss to understand they
can
fabricate steel
cheaper
they bring 60 cents into the united
states and leave with a dollar
the exchange rate
is so much different um there's
you know there's this their government
pays for their electricity in their
shops there's just so many different
factors going on
um where they can come in and sell steel
from basically below our cost
um
there was there were tariffs on steel
coming into the united states they
didn't see those tariffs you know we
were paying more for steel than they
were paying for steel so there's many
many factors where they can undercut us
and it's gotten to a point where many
steel fabrication companies have gone
out of business over the years in new
hampshire in massachusetts they just
can't compete on the bigger jobs on the
public jobs
any just about any school in
massachusetts
has been fabricated by foreign steel
many in new hampshire
thank you representative marsh and then
grota
thank you madam chair i'm uh wondering
if dan thank you for taking my question
i'm wondering if you can answer the
question that i asked senator sherman
which is uh since you're fabricating
steel where do you get the raw material
that you fabricate into your final
product correct there are many mills in
the united states and throughout the
world that
process the material from iron ore from
scrap metal
they form it into
different size members different shapes
and then it is delivered to fabricators
in a certain in a certain form usually
in 60 60 foot lengths stock lengths of
material
so
you said you lived in pennsylvania
pittsburgh used to have quite the
stealing so right so a lot of the steel
that came to fabricators came from
pittsburgh pennsylvania back in the day
it comes from other places now but still
there is still quite a bit that is
actually processed in uh united states
but we get it in its form after it's pro
after it's um manufac after it's
processed um and then we fabricate from
that material no different than a tree
being cut down in the woods and a lumber
mill makes a wood and then a carpenter
frames a house out of that wood
um
can i ask a follow-up follow up yet
uh if i look at the bill that we're
debating here on
page one line nine it says the
definition of domestic fabricated
structural steel shall mean an iron or
steel product where all the
manufacturing must take place in the
united states from the initial melting
stage and etc
if you're actually importing the steel
bars that you're then fabricating
would this then exclude you from no can
you read that again to me i'm sorry uh
what the bill yes it would it clearly
states that the
the initial from the initial melting
stage has to be done in the united
states so you would not be able to buy
foreign steel bars that if that's the
case that is even uh
it's that's not a bad thing let's put it
that way so all steel
for united states buildings for new
hampshire buildings should be
processed in in the united states
um
and that would also give the companies
that actual process the material a leg
up so that they're not dealing with the
competition yep
follow up one final product it's my un
understanding that new hampshire imports
approximately 41 million dollars per
year of canadian steel which may be
where you're getting your wrong material
from should we not and and there was
recently a trade agreement with the
government of canada about that uh would
it not be reasonable for us to change
this definition so we do not get in the
way of what's currently
been negotiated between
uh the manufacturers the smelters that
you may be getting your raw material
from
i can't answer that i'm a i'm a
fabricator
that's
more than i have than the knowledge that
i have i can see
us purchasing united states steel as a
benefit to the whole country
and i have no problem with that
whatsoever as long as we can all be
competitive
thank you thank you representative
thank you
thank you for taking my question
in um i had the opportunity to visit
novel ironworks and i found it very
fascinating
so
is your facility similar to
that
one and would it be
my two yes i'm sorry follow up excuse me
might you be interested to have
representatives who live in this area
visit your facility so that you could
show to them how complicated
this is
we'd love to have people come by
last question
um
could you
explain to the committee
how
your facility or facilities like yours
make components from engineering plans
so that you're actually building the
construction components of the building
uh excuse me i think that that would be
fascinating and would love to hear it
but i think that's a bit beyond the
scope of this particular bill in as much
as components
are specifically exempted
thank you
are there any other questions
thank you very much
thank you stephen capone
good morning uh chair mcguire vice chair
rhodes committee members
on behalf of the steel fabricators of
new england i'd like to thank you for
the opportunity to submit written
testimony and my personal testimony to
your committee in support of bill s-3438
this bill will establish a state and
local procurement policies intended to
promote
the use of american materials
as you review the benefits this bill
will bring to our communities we know
that new hampshire is not alone in this
endeavor
the same or similar bills have already
been filed in over 20 other states
and more in consideration as we speak
i've included a letter within my
distribution package
from the state of ma for the state of
massachusetts signed by multiple
companies and organizations both trade
and labor in support of the buy american
campaign
i'm owner of i'm an owner and president
of capone corporation in both raleigh
mass and
berlin new hampshire the history of
capone iron is much like you'll hear
from many of the other fabricators
testifying today
a company that has been passed on from
one generation to the next
i care about our industry and i'm
committed to seeing this bill through i
look forward to the economic success
this bill will have not only for our
communities but for our employees their
families and the surrounding communities
in new hampshire
ten years ago i took a chance on the
city of berlin new hampshire and built
capone corporation north woods
this is a state-of-the-art facility and
offers employment opportunity to an
otherwise economically challenged area
our employees are hard-working good
individuals
people who live work and spend locally
in our new hampshire towns and
communities
more importantly in addition to our
corporate tax responsibilities our
employees also pay their taxes in these
communities
herein lies our concern
new hampshire tax dollars meant to
invigorate our local economy by way of
publicly funded construction projects
are instead leaving our state and our
country because of current flawed
procurement process
contract awards going to the lowest
bidder no matter where they're from
under the misinformed guys of saving
money
the reality is when tax dollars leave
our state we lose more than the initial
savings
than by choosing a foreign fabricator
the economic multiplier indicates that
for every dollar spent a dollar fifty is
generated in the community
that means more people are employed more
people are spending money locally and we
all benefit from that
but more than that if the funds continue
to leave the state no one benefits
the perceived savings from choosing the
lowest bidder puts people out of work
employers out of business stores and
restaurants then lose customers they go
out of business and the cycle spins out
of control
when publicly funded construction
projects awarded to foreign steel
fabricators we are in effect
funding our competition to our own
demise while negatively impacting our
own communities
and supporting theirs think about that
we're funding our own demise
if these projects were awarded to
domestic steel fabricators they would
employ more workers the same workers who
spend their money in the communities
which they live and work
by all accounts foreign steel
fabrication companies have been
decimating our industry for over two
decades many of these companies are
subsidized by the governments and enjoy
favorable currency exchange
which allows them to repeatedly undercut
domestic fabricators in the bidding
process
this situation is so bad that my company
cannot justify the expense of
competitively bid on public construction
projects as we will surely lose to a
farmer fabrication company
these projects are often in our own
backyard adding insult to injury the
practice of allowing foreign steel
fabricators to bend bid and win these
publicly funded construction projects is
destroying our amer our american
industry and ultimately impacting the
people of new hampshire and the
communities they live in
as our elected officials
we employ you to take action we need to
support this bill and keep our tax
dollars here in new hampshire
the philosophy is simple
our tax dollars are meant for
meant for our publicly construction
projects need to stay within our own
domestic communities
by way of the economic multiplier the
reinvestment into our own communities
will support our local businesses our
employees and our state economy not the
economies of foreign countries
i thank you for your time and welcome
any questions you may have please
support bill 438
thank you representative fellowes has a
question
thank you mr capone um i recently read
an article in the union leader
um about a company that was
manufacturing
frames i think for bitcoin computers
is that your company or do you
no no we're we're a structural steel and
miscellaneous iron fabricator much like
the
sl chases of the world we build the um
super structures for the buildings uh
that you'll see going up
oh thank you can't just follow up so
just um
was what they were doing is that
fabrication also or not probably miss
they were doing what they call mining
and which is basically calculations well
that
that's not my question my question is
about
not what's
they're building frames for something so
i i i
know very little about crypto and all
that and i i choose not to okay it's
scary
okay
thank you very much other questions
seeing none
cliff thornberry
hello uh thank you for
allowing me the opportunity to speak to
the committee here my name is cliff
thornberry i'm one of the owners and the
president of american steel fabricators
we're in greenfield new hampshire
uh sort of out in the boonies
uh we're one of the
only manufacturing companies in that
area and we employ a lot of the local
employees
so there are there are four main reasons
why i'm supporting this bill
and
one of them obviously is personal
because i'm in this business but the
other three i think are are national
concerns
and the first one is to support
the american steel industry
now i grew up and spent almost 50 years
in pittsburgh
uh i lived in the south hills not sure
where you lived
oh okay so then i i moved to zealand
opal so i was a neighbor
so
you know my father was in the steel
industry for for lincoln electric and
when i was young
he would often take me on saturday to
some of the plants that he visit visited
and i was able to go at the age of seven
or eight to
a plant called american bridge which at
the time was the largest steel
fabricator in the world in ambridge
pennsylvania
they were started by andrew carnegie
back in the 1850s they were actually the
first corporation in america
the first construction company
corporation in the 1850s
they had 15 000 employees in that plant
it's all gone today it's a it's a
shopping center
and when i was in that plant i saw them
fabricating
the twin towers in new york city the big
panels that when the the towers fell
that there was a picture of one standing
up i saw them fabricating those panels
because it was very unique excuse me i'm
this is really fascinating but we are
we have overrun our time a bit and so if
you could concentrate on the bill i
would very much appreciate it anyway
that's one of the reasons i'm supporting
the bill the other one is is
to support the steel industry because
it's it's the most climate change
friendly product compared to concrete a
95 percent of steel is recycled it's far
and away more
environmentally friendly than concrete
the third is to support our our local
employees
and i just want to relate just an
antidote here i didn't prepare i'm sorry
i've written testimony so i have to live
with my personal antidote but
there was a project uh very close to our
plant in in in peterborough uh new
hampshire
for a library and and our a lot of our
employees lived there our controller
lives there two of our project managers
lived there there was a fund established
to build this library and everybody was
contributing and we bid on the library
and we were told by the general
contractor we had a good price and they
got the job
a few months later we said you're going
to you're going to award us this job oh
no no we gave it to a canadian company
they came in and undercut your price by
a few thousand dollars and i said well
does the town know that oh yeah the town
the town manager knows that i'm not sure
the town people knew it i'm not sure our
employees or my employees have been
asking me why didn't we fabricate this
it's five miles from our shop i lived
next door to it i sent money to it
the the gc didn't do anything illegal
um you know there was no law that says
they couldn't do that
but that's just an example of uh and
many other people who have have other
similar examples that we just can't
compete with these canadian companies i
lived there for a year and i worked for
a canadian company back in the 1970s
they get free electricity from the
government so the the plant doesn't
spend that they get free health care so
even though that's a cost the the
company itself is not spending that cost
they get tax credits
they're they're generally 10 to 20
percent cheaper than
the american companies and and we're not
asking to make a law to prohibit trade
this is only
public projects which is only about five
percent of the work in new hampshire the
other 95 percent are still private
projects there's there's nothing
you know we're not restricting free
enterprise there's really nothing you
can do in regard to private industry
we're just asking that that our tax
dollars go to support american
businesses just like all the other
countries due to us the provinces in in
canada do the same thing that we're just
we just want to get a level playing
field
so thank you for your time okay thank
you very much are there any questions
representative marsh uh the same
question i asked the other guys do you
know where you get your raw material
from
oh sure
so
when we lived in pittsburgh there were
so now
now where did you get your raw material
we get it in in steel mills from the
midwest and the south
and i don't want to see what happened
in pittsburgh happened to new hampshire
because when we lived there there were
60 operating steel mills there were 88
operating blast furnaces there's one
blast furnace left
and it all went to the south
and right now we're being beat out of
all the work from canadians to the north
and and i i you know i've been in this
business for 45 years and i've seen what
can happen and i'm just afraid that our
our industry we're not going to have
a
uh a steel industry in the united states
compared to what we do have you you are
probably familiar with the uh with the
offshore wind projects that are coming
there's a cape wind in massachusetts
that's going to build 144 offshore wind
towers those are going to come from
spain
when i was growing up in pittsburgh it
would have come from the united states
because we were the leader in large
structures no one can make that anymore
it's going to come from spain and that's
what's going to happen to our industry
if we don't do something
thank you for your testimony
thank you representative schmidt
two
president blackest you have a question
i do thank you uh madam chair
um so
i mean i've heard from you and a number
of the other people that um
because you're being undercut by foreign
producers because they're apparently
being subsidized
um
you're not able to win bids
um on the other hand so you're wanting
to you know preference for um
large state contracts
but and you said those are about five
percent
of the steel fabrication business in new
hampshire
but
somehow those don't jive for me because
how can any of you be in business right
now if you can't compete on any projects
even if we did this
you know for five percent of the
projects in the state how is that gonna
uh save any of these businesses i don't
see it so you could answer that for me
yeah sure so so we sort of get like the
leftovers and the dregs from a project
like i recently did a large project at
colby college in in maine and it was you
know a 2000 ton steel project and we got
to fabricate the stairs because super
metals in canada got the main structure
and i'm doing a project right now in
woburn massachusetts where we're going
to fabricate the stairs and the railings
because the superstructure is being done
by both both atlas and canada and and
that's happening on on many many
projects if it's a smaller project
we'll have a a better chance to get it
because someone always not as interested
in but the larger projects especially
the projects that some of my competitors
here bid that are bigger than our plant
if there's a large project and it's
private they don't even bother to bid if
there's a canadian bidder because they
know they have no chance to get it
okay thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative scitec
look i'm i'm with you i'm sitting on
this side of the table but i'm an
american i don't like the anything
all the things you're talking about but
what at school do i say it's school
district meeting when i say
when the bids come in
and they're cheaper we're going to say
it's a dollar fifty how do we
well the taxpayer doesn't care about
that he's looking at his tax bill well
that's true but let me just give you an
example um
let's
please briefly okay so suppose suppose
the bid for the steel is uh
is a million dollars
the project's 10 million dollars okay
my bid is is a million one
that's a hundred thousand dollars extra
they give it to the low bidder from from
canada for a million dollars they saved
a hundred thousand dollars on a 10
million dollar project which is one
percent but
if it's awarded to our company for a
million one
a dollar for every dollar spent here a
dollar fifty goes back into the local
economy so a million five went back into
the local economy
so
yes the taxpayers
saved a hundred thousand but a million
five went back into the local economy
and everybody paid taxes on that and
everybody was unemployed
so there's a cost benefit
yeah and you know someone smarter than
me would have to do the calculation
for the cost benefit but there's a big
cost benefit
when we're looking at a very small part
of the project that would get awarded
here thank you other questions
all right seeing none
i call holly novaletsky
good morning thank you chairman
chairperson
and vice chair
for allowing me to speak today on in
support of
senate bill 438
before i jump into this can i answer
some of the questions that have been
floating around
please that would probably be much more
useful than you're reading your
testimony okay so we do not have mills
in new hampshire we're all structural
steel fabricators we buy our mills our
material domestically
from the domestic mills our domestic
mills
are the greenest in the country in the
world
if you buy steel from outside chinese
steel for instance russian steel they
don't have the same environmental
standards or safety standards that we
install we have instill here in the
united states our steel is
90 i think it's 96
recycled material
um so we are the greenest and we buy
from the mills the only time we don't
buy domestically is if those sizes are
not available
because our mills don't produce them
as far as canada and
limiting the amount of steel that would
come in from canada raw material canada
does not have a mill
they only produce two but they do not
produce structural steel in any mill
they do not have any mills in canada
um
what else as far as your concern about
what what can this bill do really to
help our industry
the the canadians and the foreign the
foreign fabricators really have targeted
our market significantly they go after
the larger jobs the smaller jobs
less than a couple hundred tons they
really don't deal with
my company a sweet spot for us but we
are really good at doing is fifteen
hundred three thou fifteen hundred to
three thousand ton jobs your schools
your hospitals your water treatment
facilities the high rises in boston
but those are all being taken by foreign
fabricators so now i am forced to eat
into smaller and smaller markets i have
been living on the last couple years on
30 tons 50 ton jobs i am eating into the
mom and pop fabricators and going to be
pushing them out
because they can't compete against me
because i can't compete against the
foreign fabricators so what you do
is all downstream you save our public
dollars
our public construction that we as
taxpayers as you as taxpayers are paying
if you allow that to go domestic
and those are the larger jobs the
schools the libraries that people the
fabricators here
build you're saving the mom and pops
because we're not eating into their
markets anymore
i can read you my testimony i have given
you a copy
can i just highlight one last piece yes
just that we would appreciate that okay
so i wanted to give you an example
of what happened of what this bill would
do
we recently bid the nashua middle school
it's going to go it's a project that's
going to go this summer
we came in
third
we were third to two canadians our bid
was 6.9 million we lost it for half a
million dollars
but what happened was
the nashua bought the school for 6.4
they saved half a million dollars 6.4
million dollars went to canada
if you had
if they had bought the steel from us for
6.9 they would have paid 6.9 and had 8.5
million reinvested in the local
community through the multiplier effect
they had a choice to make they lost
6.4 in in reinvestment they lost 98.4 in
reinvestment by saving half a million
but that's that's in my testimony so any
questions
no i think you covered it very
thoroughly thank you very much
dean chapman
good afternoon
um name's dean chapman i'm here
representing rose steel
it's a family owned open shop structural
steel
company located in greenland new
hampshire rose has been in business
since 1983 and employs approximately 40
families
i'm asking your support on the
of the senate bill 438 an act
established in state procurement
policies intended to promote
the use of american materials
sb 438 ensures that publicly funded
construction
projects be constructed with
american-made and american fabricated
structural steel
our public tax dollars
needs to support american workers in
local economies
as part of structural the structural
steel erection company i've seen time
and time again publicly funded
construction projects of our critical
infrastructure
be erected with foreign fabricated
structural steel schools hospitals
libraries universities
and more constructed with foreign
fabricated structural steel
our tax dollars that pay for these
projects do not get reinvested into our
domestic companies american workers in
local communities
instead those tax dollars
get paid to the foreign fabricators who
take our tax dollars out of country and
out of our communities
i think you
should try to support this sb 438 and
let our public tax paid dollars support
tax paying americans in our communities
that actually generated
the money for the public dollars to be
spent
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions
seeing none
thank you thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on senate bill 438
okay seeing none i will close the public
hearing
and we are due back in 20 minutes
i've been trying to stay very quiet
the select committee senator carson
thank you very much madam chair and
members of house edna
for the record my name is sharon carson
and i represent senate district 14
comprising the towns of londonderry
hudson and auburn and i have for your
consideration this afternoon senate bill
443 relative to municipal authority
regarding the state building code um
this might sound a little familiar
because i was in here in your committee
earlier this week
and there was a section in there dealing
with this issue
and i hope that you folks will consider
the fact that um
we feel that this is a strongly about
this issue so you're seeing it again
this bill provides that the building
code review board shall review proposed
municipal amendments to the state
building code to confirm that the
proposed amendments do not conflict with
and are no less stringent than the state
building code this bill also clarifies
that fee schedules are not considered
amendments to the code and that no fee
shall be required to appeal a notice of
code violation
just again to just give a little bit of
background
back in i believe 2018
there was a study committee to look at
this because we were getting a lot of
complaints from the tradespersons
that municipalities were adopting
codes through ordinance that were
really in conflict with state building
codes
and or they had gone above those
building codes or they weren't up to
date and as you know the state for quite
a while had some issues dealing with
state building codes
and
it was at that subcommittee that we
started to lay the path to move forward
so we could get a timely
a timely adoption of the building codes
so we weren't so far behind
but one of the issues that came forward
again was the fact about the municipal
building codes
and so
we had decided that we were going to put
a process in place to deal with the
municipalities that legislation was
filed
and it was actually heard in 2019
but unfortunately it was put into an
omnibus bill that
was quite frankly overwhelming i believe
it had over 40 bills
that had been combined into one and
the range of those bills was
just about everything that you could
imagine
and the house
rejected that omnibus bill
um i was asked to bring this forward
again this year so that's why
we have the legislation in front of us
um so at this point i think i will
ask some questions i answer questions if
i can
but the folks from the building code
board are here as well as some of the
tradesmen
and women and i think
we should really listen to what the
trades men and women have to say because
they're the ones that have to deal with
the code
and one of the things we wanted to do
was have a unified code where there
would be one place
where a tradesperson could go to to find
out what were the codes in every
community as well as the state and i
believe the adoption of this would help
help that process
so
thank you very much madam chair and i'll
try to answer questions
are there any questions for the senator
thank you very much thank you very much
phillip sherman
or sheman
sherman chairman okay
oh dear god
madam chair members of the committee my
name is philip sherman i speak as chair
of the building code review board
this bill as amended reflects many hours
working with the new hampshire building
officials association the electrical
contractors business association
representatives of the electrical
licensing board the associated general
contractors the home builders
association the new hampshire municipal
association and the building code review
board as well as certain individuals who
provided valuable input
we've kept the state fire marshal
informed along the way and it now
reflects a consensus on an approach that
i believe is acceptable to all
the bill is amended by the senate
addresses the original desire for some
level of bcrb review of municipal
amendments to the state building code
and addresses both the timing of the
submission for the bcrb review by cities
and towns and the need to allow time for
the bcrb itself to review the
amendment the bill uses the term confirm
to stress that our review is only for
the purpose of confirming that a
proposed amendment does not conflict
with
and is no less stringent than the state
building code and to confirm with the
state fire marshal that it does not
conflict with the state fire code
the bill further clarifies that things
reserved the local jurisdiction by
statute such as fee schedules are not
considered amendments and therefore do
not need to come before the bcrb
after the amendment is adopted locally
the municipality is required to forward
the procedural details of the adoption
process in order to provide a high level
check that an amendment was legally
adopted
an important last point
the bill defers the effective date until
january 1st 2023 as the bcrb will need
to update its rules to address this
topic and it's clear that at least some
cities and towns will need time to
review their current ordinances and
start the process of drafting updates
prior to submitting to the bcrb for
review
at least one city for instance has yet
to update their ordinances to the 2015
codes
there's the potential that the bcrb
receives a large number of complicated
amendments in a short time frame we look
forward to working with the cities and
towns during this interim period
thank you in advance for your efforts on
this and i'm happy to answer any
questions
representative lacas thank you and thank
you for taking my question um i'm just
wondering if there's been any ongoing
process
that's looked at um
or you know municipal ordinances related
to building codes to
verify that they would be okay under
this standard um
you know the ones that are currently in
existence because this appears only to
address ones going forward
there has not
currently the cities and towns are
simply required to
send their amendments to the bcrb for
posting
not for review i believe that the grand
total of two cities or towns have done
so
so there's a lot of catch-up to do here
yeah uh follow-up
will you say it's a grand total is that
two that have made uh building code
changes to their ordinances or two that
uh sent them but others have made
changes and not sent them which
which is it two that have sent them to
us i'm aware that there are many more
that have made changes and not sent them
to us okay thank you
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
so i want to follow up on representative
leckus's uh question because that
seems to be the salient point of this at
this juncture and namely uh how much of
the
of
of the situation we have here where
there are a lot of change is being made
and potentially
changes that violate the state building
code
it seems like
that there has been effectively no or
very little review of
uh of the changes that are being made at
the local level so can you speak to that
general topic along the lines of what
representatives has already started but
uh my slight amendment if you will
yeah i think
you know you put your finger on the
issue uh there there are two pieces to
this one are
uh officials who may be creating rules
without going through the local
ordinance process and others where
ordinances may or may not be adopted
that
may be less stringent or
improperly adopted relative to rsa 155a
there's no statutory review by anybody
at this point other than just to post
them on the website so this closes that
loop and provides at least a review and
and
confirmation prior
effectiveness follow-up
so obviously to the degree that that
amendments to the state building code
are made which are more stringent
there's not a problem with that right
they're entitled to do that as long as
it's it meets the state building code
they can have something more stringent
that has been i was on the dover city
council about 25 years ago and it's my
recollection in that that we were
informed we were trained to believe that
we were okay to
uh to make a more stringent unless the
state preempted any action by the
locality that was the case in some
issues uh but uh but to the degree that
there's
essentially their post they're supposed
to post them are they supposed to post
them
you said there are only two that have
done that
to the best of my knowledge
currently you're absolutely right you
can you can amend the code as long as
it's more stringent and all you have to
do is send them to us for informational
purposes for posting
right
so follow up on that so but the the
thing is that i i know you're a busy uh
board uh i attended some of your
meetings in the past uh and that it's a
big board and it's uh
very very active
and very a lot of competent experienced
people who would be excellent at
reviewing and commenting on
on local ordinances if they ever saw
them
the question is um
it doesn't look like there's any review
at all
that's what this is intended to be
however it's a narrowly focused review
we're calling it confirmation
we're not reviewing it for the technical
appropriateness of that other than is it
more stringent than the building code
and does it conflict with the state fire
code
if somebody wants to do this and we may
or may not think they ought to do that
that's not what this is about we have no
say on okay thank you
are there any further questions
thank you very much
representative mcguire
thank you madam chair members of the
committee i'm carol mcguire merrimack 29
and this came out during the study
committee on state building codes that
we enjoyed last year
and one of the issues besides the fact
that people don't know
what the local changes to the building
code may be is that
a number of the building codes offer
alternatives you can do
you can do it with one type of conduit
or you can do a different type of
conduit and they have the details on how
you deal with that particular type of
conduit
and there either would be acceptable so
it turned out i believe that was hollis
and
and some other town adjacent to hollis
that had select had said in this town
you will use option a and the other town
said you will use option b
which
although they they were each
individually technically acceptable it
was a major confusion when you're going
back and forth across the town lines to
say
you know why why is it
this
alternative is not acceptable in this
town
and so that was
an anecdotal problem that this will help
to solve
there are also many cases of where the
town
makes a
an ordinance
that
you know seems good but it conflicts
with with the one of the building codes
or the fire code and there are no
appropriately trained people
who are approving it i mean i know my
select board would not be capable of
doing this
and so they they come up with an
ordinance that sounds good
but is in conflict with state law and so
that's what the intent of this
of this bill is is to make sure
that the
local ordinances
are not in conflict with the state
building code
they are available to people throughout
the state who know what they are and
that they are reviewed by people who are
knowledgeable that can say
you know this is this is in conflict
with our state with the fire code in
this section which you hadn't considered
or
you know your your next your next door
town
has picked the other option
and is this really important
but
the building code review board does not
have the authority to
cancel
they don't have to approve them they
just have to say yes it's in it meets
requirements you you town go ahead and
adopt it
uh for example i believe the town of
durham
chose to relocate itself from
climate
zones five which at most the state is to
climate zone six
which would ensure
uh greater insulation in the town well
that's stricter than the built state
building code and it would be
be so reviewed and say yes you can do
that that's within your authority but
make sure everybody knows about it
and
so this is for
consistency and transparency above all
and i'll try to answer questions
thank you chairman representative
schmidt
thank you madam chair i'm so mad
madam committee chair
uh first of all in leading to my
question i want to salute the fact that
you have been paying a lot of attention
and it seems to me like you're certainly
have made yourself one of the more
knowledgeable state legislators anyway
with regard to such issues but i'm very
concerned about
uh the the the situation uh that with
the small towns the the bigger cities
i'm sure dover has a a building
inspector
matter of fact i know who it used to be
i don't know what it is at the moment um
and
and and it has an active inspection
process and
numerous requirements and so forth but
the small towns very often is it not the
case of the small towns it's the select
board or one of the selectmen who is
the building inspector
that seems to me to be an awfully
loosey-goosey situation can you talk
about that well sure my town doesn't
have we we don't have a building
inspector as such we have a code
enforcement officer
who checks for a number of
code enforcement issues
uh when we were building our house we
found out he checks for
setbacks he checks for road
driveway position
location of the well and the septic
and
but the actual structure of the house
was
the responsibility of the contractor and
this bill would not change any of that
and for example epsom would not even
think about adopting
an amendment to the state building code
because we don't have any ability to
enforce it and the building code is
pretty is reasonable so we wouldn't we
wouldn't think about it the the i'm sure
the amendments are coming from the
cities in the larger towns
follow-up follow-up so one of the issues
that i'm also concerned about is
i mean contractors and i'm i'll ask if
any of them are going to be
testifying i'll ask them the question
but do the do the masters
and even the journeymen do they not have
an ethical co responsibility
as members of profession with
a
code of ethics
at least of a sort
to
abide by building code requirements
yes they do
and in fact when you sign a contract
with a builder you generally agree on
what building code you're going to use
right i remember when with the when
dover was building a
a
community works
facility we had a clerk of the works
that was employed by the city to oversee
the process
of the construction and so forth and i
as the chairman of that
committee went out on frequent occasions
to observe the process and notice that
the craftsmen were very very
focused on
doing things and they said we wonder
whether this citizens of dover have any
idea what kind of a
very high quality building they're
getting they were very proud of the work
that they were doing which i was
gratified to see because also the
engineer the architect i should say who
was uh responsible for the design
senator schmidt
i'm i'm sorry is there a que is there a
question for the right oh there's always
a question at the end of my dialogue
let's get to the questions um so the
question is
do you feel that that the the citizens
are sufficiently protected
even before this bill
with regard to getting the getting what
they're paying for i don't believe that
this bill would change the current
situation in any way whatsoever
the
matter of building inspectors and
supervision of contracts is something
that every person or organization that
puts makes a building
is responsible for
that's in your case the city of dover
and in my case my
dan and i built a house we did some
supervision we hired other people to
to do inspections
because we can't you know
but if you want it if you want to uh
this doesn't affect that if you want to
talk about requiring building inspectors
in other towns or whatever
that's
an entirely separate piece of
legislation i think that's important for
the committee to know thank you madam
chair
and thank you madam chair representative
lekis
thank you um i think from reading the
legislation and the previous answer i i
think i i know the answer to this but
i'm not sure and that is
if there are existing uh building codes
created by towns
and they never bothered to send them to
the
state
would this have any impact on them at
all unless they went to i guess update
them or something
uh no it doesn't it doesn't seem to be
retrospective
however
the fact that we now be looking at
future and updated building codes might
imply might
inspire more towns to send any previous
amendments just for information purposes
okay thank you
we didn't want to impose
excessive costs on the tents
are there any further questions
thank you madam chairman
mr abbott
thank you madam chairman and for the
record committee my name is gary abbott
i'm the executive vice president of the
associated general contractors of new
hampshire
and we're here today in full support of
senate bill 443
i first want to recognize the great
effort that senator carson
representative mcguire
the building code review chairman
sherman and their efforts over the last
year i mean as you heard before
there are really three bills and they
intersect
this is the last one that this committee
is going to hurt here i guess so
i i will stick to that but i think the
other bills matter in your recent
questioning
from a contractor perspective we're
fully in support because
if towns file their amendments
it'll be in one location for everyone to
see online
and that's a great benefit whether it's
the city or town
the construction architects
just to have it centralized because
currently a contractor that does work in
different communities has to check with
that community for any amendments to the
code
so the thought is is in the future those
amendments would all be in one place in
a great resource
even beyond the check whether it's uh
either more stringent or less stringent
this will be a great item
i also want to address the
the your discussion regarding old
amendments
understand uh house bill 1681 is
updating the code
that's happening this year we're going
from 2015 to 2018.
some of those amendments are going to be
null and void because the new code's
going to have incorporated either a more
stringent or a higher standard so
there's going to be a continual practice
if a town wants to
update an amendment to which code
so as we go through this cycle
of getting closer because we did get
behind
as the cycle codes i think there'll be
less amendments by municipalities
because of the reasons you've already
heard
the expertise is really with the
building code review board and all of
those specialties
that's where they that's and they are
the ones reviewing the next code
so i'm looking at it they'll be less and
less need for the towns to update their
code feeling that they're behind since
we'll be caught up so i think yeah i'm
looking at is in the totality
of what's happening within the
legislature with all three of the bills
this is one piece that i don't think you
have to go back and look because i think
it's going to automatically happen
the amendments are going to be to an
older code not to the newer code so i
think this thing is going to end up
being much better for towns because they
i think there will be
less instances in which they feel the
need to go more stringent because the
code will be more current and so
i would hope this committee
you have to understand
anytime you have a bill that the home
builders
i represent commercial construction most
of our projects are designed by
architects
but when you look at all the groups that
are involved in this the building code
officials
all of them that have come together and
i'll support this i think i would hope
that the committee would support the
senate bill 443
thank you representative lucas thank you
uh again back to i guess existing um
town amendments the building code
and i understand you know we adopt a new
building code and their amendments you
know their building code updates may be
obsolete
my question is is there any process of
cleaning those out other than an
architect or a contractor discovers in
trying to do some work that there are
stale or obsolete or incompatible
local town ordinances and somehow you
know brings that to someone's attention
or is that stuff basically to sit there
until somebody runs into it as a problem
my my hope is is that this is the first
step to get that process in
i agree with you we may have some of
those but i think the building code
review board and working with cities and
towns maybe the municipal association
others we we could clean that up so
you're absolutely right an architect's
going to hit that or a building contract
is going to see that it's not necessary
and hopefully towns will go through the
process of removing those amendments if
they're not shouldn't be in place or
updating them but i think we're going to
go through a period of time i
i think it would over complicate the
bill to try to have the building code
review board look at all past amendments
all at once i think that could be
problematic moving forward okay thank
you i agree i just uh
was was concerned for the people having
to deal with these codes about having
potentially conflicting things they're
supposed to yeah it would be great if
this bill goes through and then cities
and towns go through this process i
think they'll probably look at all of
their amendments and hope that would be
what they would do hope so thank you
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
so mr abbott you know you and i have
gone around and around for many years
since uh
i got on this committee 16 years ago um
uh and i'm wondering i mean this is the
live free or die state and and obviously
when you have a
uh
a
couple that buys a a contractor services
to build a home if it's a couple like
the mcguires who um
the
representative mcguire and former
representative mcguire are both very
smart people and she's an engineer
so i think you're going to get a more
buyer beware couple
uh
than you did with in many cases so
but what i'm concerned about is are we
is our situation in new hampshire
way too loosey-goosey with regard to
adherence to codes and so forth in areas
where the inspection capabilities are
much
more rudimentary than they are in the
cities i i don't think so representing
contractors for some 35 years
it's clear that the construction
industry wants to build to the latest
code or a higher code
we can't build to a lesser code because
of the liability issues
everyone involved in a process project
and i think you would hear a lot of
newspaper stories if things were being
shoddy done especially in the commercial
end
i don't think you get that
and i don't think this bill in any way
affects the current inspection process
third-party inspections a lot of people
don't realize there's a lot of processes
when you're doing uh
especially in our case large commercial
projects there's a number of things that
are done for the owner's purpose of
testing things
so that's not been an issue for us
and we really look towards the architect
to design based on the code that's in
place and i think these three bills
really are a complement to
straightening out some of the loose ends
that we've had in years past but i don't
i don't think it has any effect
on the inspection process or
all of those the building code officials
but it's great to have the building code
officials that support this as well
well
i'm very glad to hear uh your remarks
because
uh
that's very heartening for me as a
non-engineer to know that that the
industry
really does care and that is trying to
do things right and improve things
perhaps you recall a couple of years ago
we had a discussion in this committee
that was facilitated by the fact that we
have
two
former firefighters to my right and
several other firefighters on the
committee or had them in the past
and there was a colloquy about whether
the
construction of the
uh the basement
uh
basically the
the ceiling of the basement right
there was some kind of
more modern or
representative schmidt is this a
question or can you keep this for the
executive session
is it a question is there a question or
can you keep what you're discussing for
the executive session
i think it's a there's a question
because
there was a real discussion whether the
whether that newfangled concept was
going to burn through too fast to
protect the thing and my request my
recollection is that the
um
that the committee wisely turned down
at
the uh you know
the insistence of the firefighters that
that was not in their opinion something
was safe you recall that colloquy i do
recall that that really had to do with
uh residential construction but it is
part of the process of amendments that
happened with the building code review
board so i think we're not affecting
that process that clearly was
an item that was
in negotiations between the parties that
you talked about but i think that was
completely resolved you're going to hit
those over the years whenever you have a
new code whether it's through the fire
code or whether it's the billing code
but i don't think it pertains to
this 443 in the sense that
this is really about filing amendments
from the local level
good
thank you thank you representative
fellows
thank you madam chair
um my question is i'm just concerned
about the
administrative process and how long
that's going to take and how long it's
going complicated it's going to be
after a town a small town
makes a change
they
they vote on an amendment to the
building code
and it just seems very complicated to me
that first they have to send it
to the board
and the board has to look at it and
approve it
and then there's an administrative
person involved because you're going to
have to hire a new staff and then it's
going to have to be put on on the web
and
it just seems like a lot of
paperwork
kind of stuff in and that
i don't is the board going to approve
everything it sees within
a week or two weeks or how often does
the board meet in town little towns have
their meetings all at the same time in
the spring basically
i'm going to say that i'm probably not
the best one to talk about this but i do
know the building code review board jam
and chairman
went through a lot of these same
questions when they went through
amending it to get it to this point
that a lot of those issues were resolved
with how they're not an approval process
they're a review process
and i don't i think right now i
recognize that in the statute it says
towns are supposed to send it to the
building code review board but some are
not
this gives a little more that there's
some indication they get at least
whether it
is good or bad
i understand your concern but i think
i'm hopeful that with the passage of new
codes there will be less filings and it
won't be that big a burden in the long
run there may be a little influx at the
beginning but i don't think it'll be
that otherwise i think the building code
review board
chairman would be here telling you he
didn't want to do this
mr sherman did you want to answer that
question great escape
so we work carefully with margaret burns
from the new hampshire municipal
association on this issue
and i only partly understand the forms
of town and city government in new
hampshire but as i understand it
uh cities have a relatively large degree
of florida not even interests in the
cities
i'm interested in the small towns can
you just speak to that
okay so there's a very narrow band of
small towns that are involved in this
process and here's the reason why
unless you have adopted this the rsa 674
process which involves hiring a building
inspector and so forth you can't amend
the code so that cuts off most of the
small small towns they have nothing to
do with this process because they
legally can't amend the code anyway so
there's a fairly narrow band of towns
that are large enough to have a building
inspector
small enough where these things have to
go through the town meeting cycle
so the effort was to provide a time
frame that aligned according to margaret
burns with the town meeting cycle which
is the tight one when things have to be
posted and public hearings and so forth
while still giving the cities who have
much more latitude time wise because
they're dealing with city council or
whatever
and don't have those pressures of time
quite so much that's why the
many words and the different time frames
so my question had to do with when they
send you a
change how long in this process seems to
be that the
the board has to review them and then it
gets passed to an administrative person
how long is that gonna take are you
gonna
we're comfortable at this point that we
can meet the timing in this proposed
bill
understand that many of these are
repetitive
there are several jurisdictions that
want to require a manual pull station
fire alarm pull station where the model
codes don't
it may be that through our rules as we
go through the process of updating that
that becomes almost a matter of form
approval so it may not have to go to the
whole board because they may approve it
as a as a
standard approval if you will of some
sort uh but there's a fair amount of
repetition to that
um
many of the problems we've found have
have had to do with officials creating
rules without going through the
ordinance process at all
or
properly approved ordinances that get
stale and get out of date
so that's going to be a i think
something as gary said
is going to get updated over time to a
degree
um
but i think we're we're going to be able
to keep up with these time frames
and
there's language in the bill here to
protect the towns in that if we don't
keep up with our end of the bargain the
default is that they are treated as
confirmed
some are unhappy with that language but
that's what's in here
did you have an another follow-up
representative fellows
so the things that are going to be stale
and out of date how are you going to
identify those
you don't have to dig very hard
to find
the cities that
haven't yet updated
right
i'm asking about towns
statutorily it's not up to us to find
that
this bill says they can't enforce it
unless they're confirmed
we're not
we're not looking to be the policeman of
finding this stuff
it's it's a feed to us and then back to
back to the towns
there i think will be a courtesy
discussion prior to january for the ones
we find but
but this this bill does not include the
time or the effort to act as the
policemen and
chase existing problems around
representative schuett
thank you madam chair that sort of goes
to the question that was
going through my mind i don't see any
kind of
penalty for a municipality that doesn't
comply with this was that considered at
all
not to my knowledge
there
there may be penalties embedded in
rsa 674 which is where
the reporting requirements resides i i
don't know
are there any further questions
thank you again
i i know i'm not going to be able to
pronounce this so i
i'm a henry
that is not at all what i was going to
say
good afternoon my name is henry zumas
i'm here representing the new hampshire
electricians board
i'm one of the concurrent members
as far as our board goes this we're
fully in favor of this bill
the new hampshire legislators many years
ago have provided the state with a board
to oversee all national construction and
building and fire codes
this board covers the interests of the
fire marshal architects general
contractors mechanical and plumbing
contractors and electricians
it also is a portal to know the uh what
year of code
and
amendments to those code that the state
of new hampshire is following
as senate bill 443 brings
information from the towns and cities uh
of local amendments to the board that
has been given oversight and public
forum to view and comment on
this information will also allow
citizens of the state
code enforcement developers project
architects engineers general contractors
and subcontractors a one star preview of
what is required
by code in the state of new hampshire
our electricians board prides itself
with the requirements of all licensed
electricians to do a code update course
every three years to keep up with
changes in our industry and during this
time all providers review the amendments
of the state the state of new hampshire
has with our national electrical code
this has prepared our electricians for
upcoming changes even before new
hampshire adopts these codes
in closing senate bill 443 will enhance
the education of the state and local
requirements for for construction in
towns and municipalities
i thank you for this time for let me
speak and i'm hoping for any
okay any questions
see none thank you
like to call uh stephen rancourt
good morning mr chairman and committee
members my name is steven ryancourt i'm
an electrical contractor in the state of
new hampshire and i'm also here
representing the ecba electrical
contractors business association
um
as stated by senator carson this bill is
started years ago in our working process
we support this bill and hope that
you'll move it forward
again it's just really trying to focus
on
having a central spot
for all these different code changes or
amendments from the local authorities so
that we know what they are and what we
found in the processes as has been
mentioned before they're not aware of
some of them especially the towns the
actual legal process they're supposed to
go through by the law now so this helps
give them that guidance make sure that
they've done it and again make sure that
it doesn't conflict with the codes or
it's not less stringent then it gives us
a central location when we're doing any
work to go and look and see if it's
there what those are
instead of trying to find them
individually for every town for in 225
cities or whatever there are towns and
cities across the state
and this was part of the concerns that
i've heard brought up and maybe i can
answer this a little bit is this isn't
going to really slow down a process or
cause any issues with the town the new
the way that the law is now for adopting
codes after a long process before um
is the code's trying to stay roughly one
cycle behind and so they have two years
while they're going through the process
of adopting the new code to put this
forward plenty of time there's not going
to be a delay by the building the pump
the building code review board probably
because they meet once a month
occasionally they miss the summer month
for whatever reason but they meet every
month pretty much and they would deduct
they would take it up then if not but
they have two years right now they're
trying to adopt the 2018 code in in
senate bill and house bill 1681 and
that's going to adopt those codes but
they're also working on the 2021 codes
so they're already there so if they have
these amendments they have plenty of
time and penalty opportunity to bring
these forward and submit them and go
through the billing code board so
hopefully that answers some of the
questions it's it's important to give us
that central location for everything and
understand it and just make sure they're
following properly you know we run into
some situations in the town where as
representative maguire try to explain
i live in pelham work in pelham and
hudson right over the border one town
requires allows us to put the wire on
the service
with the wire the next town a thousand
feet over i have to put it in conduit
don't really live in a different climate
or atmosphere or anything different but
some of the inspectors want certain
things and this just allows us to make
sure we're aware of what they are
when we go to work in the town so be
glad to answer any questions
thank you any questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you
um any other members from the public
who'd like to sp speak on house bill or
senate bill i'm sorry 443
all right
and uh
and if you can uh at least after
speaking fill out a pin card please
it's for the record well at least after
when you're speaking if you could please
fill out a pink card and bring it up for
the record thank you will do thank you
my name is raymond hebert i am the vice
president of the largest electrical
contracting firm in state of new
hampshire
we are in favor of this bill and the
reason for this bill which would help
each and every one of us as a contractor
is to find a home where we can review
the codes that are being changed or the
amendments that are being changed these
small towns so we are in favor of this
bill
thank you thank you any questions from
the committee
okay see none thank you anyone else from
the public who wants to speak
okay see none i'm going to close the
public hearing on senate bill 443
and i'm going to reopen i guess the
public hearing that was recessed on
senate bill
313 and recognize
senator gaida
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record uh bob guydis
senator from district 2 and prime
sponsor on senate bill 313.
this is kind of the bill that would not
die
uh pandemic omnibus all whatever but
it's a very necessary bill and i'm of
the understanding that there may be some
amendments to it because of work this
committee has done on the house side and
i'm fine with that
office of professional licensure and
certification has been somewhat of a
bastard stepchild since its inception
and
it's had gone through a number of
directors gone through a number of
of changes in location uh cost structure
changes and so forth under under the
current stewardship of executive
director lindsey courtney i think it's
going in the right direction
uh this bill is helping to solve
problems that we have with the
relationship between the director and
the boards and those are problems
sometimes related to
authority
uh sometimes related to
[Music]
knowledge base and so forth so we're
morphing from the old system into the
new where oplc will be basically the
oversight system for administration of
fees and
um and application process for
i would say the entire panorama of
agencies of which there are numbers
many as you know
so um
it um
it it takes out specific fee amounts
that are currently in statute
and enables then the body the the
governing board or the licensure board
to work with the oplc director to
establish a fee consistent with what the
law says 125 provision and so forth some
of those uh organizations some of the
boards are not within that some are some
are paying way too much some are paying
not enough that all gets worked out and
i think that'll probably be the result
of the study committee
in whatever form that study committee
comes out as i said i spoke to
chair maguire and
she's indicated that you've done some
work on that the point is we need to
solve the problem get that oplc up into
a state of operating efficiency that'll
do the job we intended to do six years
when we put it together six years ago
i'll take any questions
thank you any questions to the committee
um
peter representative schmidt
thank you mr chairman good to see you up
there sir
uh good afternoon senator so uh the the
purpose of the
study committee
is a little bit limited and i'm
wondering whether
you
would be comfortable with the idea
that the that the committee
could look at
other issues that arise
in their deliberations
with regard to the pursuit of
improvement in the operation of oplc
uh
along this you know specific specified
lines
because you know
some of us on the committee have been
working on this for a long time and are
very concerned about getting oplc to be
more in the direction
of uh what what was intended originally
um and and i i wouldn't want to see the
study committee
uh overlook something that
maybe is not
narrowly what it's supposed to be doing
i know that the the the request to look
at
um relative to the funding was
specifically from the executive director
and so
whilst i would not have an objection to
going beyond that
i would certainly make certain that was
still an integral part of that study
committee and i would also suggest a
request that you clear it with with uh
with director courtney
thank you
uh any other questions for the committee
seeing none thank you thank you mr is
there anyone else from the public here
who wants to speak on senate bill 313
see none i'm going to close the hearing
on senate bill 313.
mr chair
yes could i make an announcement please
certainly i just want to let committee
members know that i went to the clerk's
office and
got a copy of
the amendment to senate bill 358 which
we're going to be hearing next tuesday
and there were extra copies i brought i
was getting one for myself so i brought
them for everybody thank you
anything else and uh i'll leave turn it
over to chair maguire
here
uh
okay
all of these bills need to be exact
no later than tuesday
i am working on amendments
to 443 and 313
um
and
like i said if anyone wants to talk to
me about any either of them i'd be
delighted
i will be sending them out this weekend
i expect
what else
what are the other ones
are you intending to exec any bills
today
i don't think so we don't there are a
number of people who aren't here
and i told the people who said they were
going to be here that would only exact
the obvious and i don't and
after the hearings i doubt if any of
these are obvious
just want to make sure thank you
so
we will be executing these on tuesday
most likely
and therefore if you're not going to be
here on tuesday please
let me know and i will deal with the
majority or minority office to get a
replacement
and that i think is the main thing and
i'll talk about any of the uh
yeah talk to me in person about the
amendments and we'll um
if you have if you have any other
amendments please do uh get them and
send them out as far in advance as you
can
john
443 needs an amendment
uh the last line because the building
code review board wants to make sure
they have the procedural history before
finally
approving
so
it says it the
shall be submitted to the board within
30 days of enactment or adoption i just
wanted to add and prior to enforcement
okay
that's all
while it may not take a lot of time what
about the 363 the group two do you think
that's going to come is that an issue
that one might be that's the only one i
could see we might possibly do today do
you want to make a motion i i'll move uh
ought to pass on 363. hey second
okay
i reserve the right to uh
recess this if it appears to be
more controversial
okay
the case made
by
the
people who supported this bill was that
it was an attempt to head in the
direction of fairness
and i think we
uh should support that
uh my view is i really don't like the
build because while i don't want to do
the work i do not like the idea that you
missed by two months and you are out
you've got to do the whole
buy out thing there should have been i
don't like
cliffs i like ramps
i'm not as i said prepared to do the
work at this hour
on that bill but at least this is a step
in the right direction so on the grounds
of
fairness uh
limited fairness i support the concept
the bill
okay and the second was by president
broder do you wish to speak to your
second i'd like to add thank you yes
thank you
madam chair i'd like to add that
the
um burden of this buyback is on the
employee
and we heard testimony today that there
is there are interested
people that would take advantage of this
and
therefore i
um sucking into the bill and support
representative syjek's motion
right anyone else representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
so i i thought that we were going to
see in
a motion to approve
363 as well
i i thought the case in and
made in support
of the bill was so overwhelming uh that
um
that even though it
puts all the burden
on the employees when the
fault
of
the uh
the situation that that uh caused the
the
the uh
change in the statute back in about 2006
was uh was not theirs um nevertheless we
put them in a box
that uh that
that they need some kind of relief and
even if this is an imperfect bill uh i
think it moves in the right direction
and does something for
these people who are clearly under a lot
of duress so i will enthusiastically
vote yes
representative schuett
thank you madam chair yes
i was reminded while we were
having the hearing on this bill of
those of us who've been on the committee
for a little while recall
an attempt that representative pearson
made to try and
rectify the
case of many of these folks
we literally had dozens
of people who were in this position come
in and testify
while this bill doesn't make them
as whole as that bill would have i
certainly wholeheartedly support
uh the attempt to give them some kind of
respite
representative
representative lackas
thank you yeah i came into this uh not
really having an objection to the bill
but being skeptical there was any point
to it given the amount of money people
have to pay but
given the testimony especially from the
lady from the department of corrections
i understand
why they might want it and
and so i think it's worth the small
amount of money startup money to to go
ahead and do this i support it thank you
okay
anyone else
yeah i i would say that
offering these people the opportunity to
improve their pensions at their own cost
is
you know something that we can't i don't
think we can legitimately deny
all right anyone else
imperfect bills are my specialty ah
that's good to know you have we have one
very good
all right uh in that case the motion is
ought to pass on house bill 363 and the
clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes
she's not here
yeah oh goodness well level you're
probably gonna vote yes uh yes
representative jacobovic yes
representative leccas yes representative
allegro yes
representative bailey
no
representative
goalie
yes
representative schuett yes
representative
schmidt
hi
representative marsh yes
representative fellows
yes
representative product
representative o'brien yes and the chair
yes
something to one
eleven i get twelve
what's that one twelfth one okay that
sounds about right
two four six i got twelve to one twelve
thirteen yeah there's thirteen people
present so it shouldn't be twelve
is there any objection to consent
no
okay
representative scitec you can write the
report at your uh earliest convenience
okay
i'll email you that's perfectly fine
all right and
okay
thank you all
and uh
we will see you on monday
we're
with any luck you'll get called early
enough
amendments on two
get your amendments done and um because
uh we might do them with very easily
443 should be
440.
you